ausländische
[Musik]
Wir sind am 20. Oktober 2022 im aktiven Inferenz-Livestream
Nummer 50.1.
Wir diskutieren das Abfangen von Papier
als Modellierung der Allostase als Kontrolle.
Willkommen beim Institut für aktive Inferenz.
Wir sind ein partizipatives Online-
Institut, das kommuniziert  Lernen
und Üben von angewandter aktiver Inferenz
Dies ist eine Aufzeichnung in einem archivierten Live-
Stream. Bitte geben Sie Feedback, damit wir
unsere Arbeit verbessern können.
Alle Hintergründe und Perspektiven sind
willkommen. Befolgen Sie die Video-
Etikette für Live-Streams.
Besuchen Sie activeinference.org, um mehr darüber zu erfahren
wie man sich an verschiedenen
Lerngruppen und Projekten wie den
Live-Streams beteiligt und ansonsten sind
wir hier in Live-Stream Nummer 50.1
mit unserer zweiten Diskussion über das Abfangen von Papieren
als Modellierung von Allostase als
Kontrolle.
Vorher hatten wir Nummer 50.0, wo Dean
und ich einige Hintergrundinformationen geliefert haben  und
Kontext und jetzt sind wir wirklich
dankbar, dass wir einige
Autoren haben werden, die sich für den Punkt eins anschließen  und zwei
, um einige Ideen auszupacken und zu erkunden,
und ähm, heute wird es großartig sein, von mehreren Autoren zu hören,
eine kleine
Präsentation zu sehen und in die Mitte
der Dinge einzutauchen, wie wir es in Punkt eins tun,
und damit beginnen wir  Einführungen,
dann werden wir eine Präsentation und
dann eine Diskussion haben, also beginnen wir zuerst mit
Einführungen mit Nicht-Autoren, und
sie können sich frei fühlen, Hallo zu sagen
und alles, was sie heute entdecken möchten,
also bin ich Daniel, ich bin ein
Forscher in Kalifornien
und ich freue mich darauf,
einige der Formalismen im Modell zu verstehen und
wie sie mit aktiver Inferenz und
Bayes'scher Mechanik zusammenhängen, und ich gebe an Dave weiter
Jacques
punks it und Mark soles Ich lebe in der
kilometerhohen akademischen Stadt Baguio, 200
Kilometer nördlich von Manila Dean,
danke Dave, ich bin Dean, ich bin in Calgary,
was mich interessiert, ist, dass dies
auf einer metaphorischen Ebene mit
mir begann  in einem offenen Feld und ich bekam  in
einen Wald und dieser Wald wurde dichter und
verbeulter, und als wir bei Abschnitt
vier dieser Zeitung ankamen, fing ich an, ihn
immer und immer wieder
zu lesen, was ein fantastisches Zeichen ist, denn wenn ich etwas viele Male lesen muss,
um wirklich meinen Verstand zu bekommen
darum herum, dass das gut ist, weil ich Dinge nicht in Frage stelle, es
sei denn, ich verstehe sie nicht, das
bedeutet nicht, dass es nicht
richtig geschrieben wurde, es bedeutet nur, dass Sie
meine Aufmerksamkeit erregt haben, also
bin ich mir nicht sicher, welcher Autor  Um
es zuerst an Eli weiterzugeben, würdest du gerne
sagen: Hallo,
hallo an alle,
ähm, ich bin Eli, ich bin der erste Autor dieses
Papiers,
also
ähm, kurz bevor der Live-Stream begann,
erwähnte Jordan, dass diese Arbeit
aus dem hervorgeht, was wir sind  Wir haben
in unserem Labor in einer
Energetik-Arbeitsgruppe zusammen studiert
, bevor
die Pandemie uns wirklich getroffen hat,
und als ich
eingesperrt war,
wissen Sie, dass ich effektiv angefangen habe zu lesen
und wieder zu lesen, wissen Sie, alles, was
wir durchgemacht und versucht haben,
aufzutauchen  mit etwas  Art
, über Allostase nachzudenken, denn
in unserer Gruppe und in unseren früheren
Veröffentlichungen als Gruppe haben
wir uns viel auf Allostase bezogen,
und jedes Mal würde ich Sie fragen, wie
wir eine mathematische oder
rechnerische Charakterisierung
von Allostase I geben können  würde im Grunde gut gesagt werden,
Sie wissen, wir dachten, Peter Sterling hätte
einen,
und dann würde ich mir Peter Sterling ansehen,
und
er ist übrigens der Urheber des Konzepts der
Allostase, also gibt es
zahlreiche Arbeiten von ihm zu diesem Thema,
wahrscheinlich die längste Form
, sagen wir mal
nein  -Expertenbehandlung wäre wahrscheinlich
sein Buch, was Gesundheit ist,
hey,
und wenn ich mir
Sterlings Arbeit ansehe, würde ich irgendwie einen
Widerspruch oder einen Widerspruch in
Bezug
auf einen erkennen, dass er auf der einen
Seite speziell die Variation
der physiologischen Parameter und der
Regulierung im
Laufe der Zeit aufzeichnet wo  Zeit kann im Laufe der Entwicklung der Lauf
eines Lebens sein
oder auch nur der Lauf eines
einzigen Tages
und doch weiter  Auf der anderen Seite, wenn Sie ihn gut fragen,
wie das gemacht wird, würde er
effektiv
sagen, dass dies durch
Verstärkungslernen über die dopaminergen Systeme
im Gehirn geschieht.
Jetzt verfolgen die dopaminergen Systeme im
Gehirn kein sich änderndes Signal im Laufe der
Zeit, sie maximieren nur die Belohnung
und so waren sie meiner Ansicht nach zumindest als
Computerspezialist eher
homöostatisch als allostatisch,
und aus diesem Widerspruch und den daraus resultierenden Folgen
kam
dieser ganze Artikel wirklich
fremd,
aber um es noch einmal zu betonen, würde ich sagen, und
bevor wir uns mit
Folienmaterial befassen  In der Zeitung
denke ich, dass es sich wirklich lohnt zu betonen,
nur basierend auf dem Ansehen des 50.0-Livestreams
, dass
unsere Gruppe eher Biologen
und Physiologen als
Physiker sind,
also Bayesian, die Arbeit über die Bayes'sche
Mechanik kam heraus, während wir dies schrieben,
und ich nicht  Ich denke, wir haben es wirklich geschafft,
die beiden Materialgruppen noch
zusammen
oder zusammen zu integrieren
, aber das heißt nicht, dass sie es nicht können oder
sollten  integriert bedeutet, dass
wir sozusagen nicht immer das
Fachwissen über Physik und dynamische Systeme
von jemandem wie Thomas Parr oder Maxwell
Ramstead haben, ganz zu schweigen von Karl Kristen,
andererseits haben
wir sehr konkrete Vorstellungen davon, was
Biologie und  Physiologie, an die wir uns anpassen müssen,
da der Großteil dieses Papiers wirklich
der Grund dafür ist, dass es nicht nur ein kurzer
Abschnitt mit etwas Mathematik
ist, weil wir uns an die
Physiologie und Anatomie anpassen müssen, über die wir Bescheid wissen.
Danke, Jordan
dann geht Eli auf jeden Fall zu Ihnen für eine
Präsentation, also bin ich
Postdoc im Labor hier, also denke
ich, dass ich vielleicht nur einen Kontext geben werde, wo
wir beide arbeiten und wie wir
hierher gekommen sind, also
für mich  Ich hatte einen etwas seltsamen Weg,
um an diesen Punkt zu gelangen, da ich meinen Doktortitel
in Sozialpsychologie und Moralpsychologie gemacht habe,
ähm,
es ist dann eine Art Transsexuelle, die sich
wirklich sehr für
Perspektiven der prädiktiven Verarbeitung und aktive
Schlussfolgerungen interessierte und es dann wirklich wollte  grabe
ich  Dazu und jemanden finden, der
hier in Boston daran arbeitet, also
arbeite ich schnell mit Lisa Feldman Barrett und
Karen zusammen, die das
interdisziplinäre Labor für affektive Wissenschaften
hier gemeinsam
leiten, und wie ihr sagt, die
Perspektive, die wir haben, ist wirklich mehr
von einem biologisch fundierten oder mehreren
von einem, der in Physiologie
und Neurowissenschaften basiert Also scherzen Lisa und Carol,
dass Lisa alles
vom Hals aufwärts regelt und Karen
alles vom Hals abwärts regelt, also
bilden sie zusammen eine ganze Person
ähm
und was  Was ich wirklich glücklich machte,
war, dass ich über
eine bestehende Zusammenarbeit stolperte, die
etwa ein Jahrzehnt hier bestand,
die wir die Psychologie-
Ingenieur-Neurowissenschaftsgruppe oder die
Stiftsgruppe nennen,
wo es eine laufende
Zusammenarbeit mit ähm Professoren in der
Elektrotechnik gibt  Abteilung,
wahrscheinlich am wichtigsten, Dana Brooks
hat wirklich viel dazu beigetragen, dass
Dennis Abdogmas und Jennifer D beide
auch l waren  Ich bin wirklich wirklich in
dieses
ähm involviert und sie würden sich also
jede Woche treffen und sie würden irgendwie
durchkommen mit aktiven Interessenpapieren, die
Papiere verarbeiten, äh, Informationstheorie,
sie würden uns Neurowissenschaftlern irgendwie beibringen, uns
zu beschleunigen
Verständnis von Technik und
wir versuchen, sie auch mit einer Art
biologischem Verständnis der Neurowissenschaften vertraut
zu machen.
Was uns also wirklich interessiert hat
, ist
, über einige der Abstraktionen nachzudenken
, die im Akt der Inferenzliteratur
aufgetaucht sind  und darüber nachzudenken, wie man
diese biologischen Prozesse erden kann
und wie man dies wirklich
auf einer empirischen biologischen Ebene handhabbar macht, und
so war mein Interesse an
Gehirnenergetik eine Möglichkeit, etwas von dieser Zugkraft
auf
mein ursprüngliches Interesse anzuwenden  Das ist eine Art
moralischer und sozialer Normen, also habe ich ein
bisschen daran gearbeitet,
darüber nachzudenken, wie wir über
Informationen oder energetische Kosten der
Informationsverarbeitung als einen Weg nachdenken können  darüber,
wie Individuen Kontrolle über ein
soziales Umfeld ausüben, indem sie den darin enthaltenen
Erwartungen entsprechen,
und gleichzeitig war ich daran
interessiert, zum anderen Ende zu gehen
und über einige der
Details des Gehirnstoffwechsels und des
Glukosestoffwechsels im Gehirn nachzudenken
mit dem Bold fmri-Signal verbunden, so dass wir
wirklich tiefer in den
Stoffwechsel eintauchen können, der der neuronalen Bildgebung zugrunde liegt,
ihr Bild in der Literatur,
ähm, aber im Prozess, dies im Grunde
durchzuführen oder diese
Energetik-Lesegruppe zu bilden, in der wir
uns mit allem beschäftigt haben  diese Themen,
um zu versuchen, die Biologie des Gehirns zu verstehen.
Eli und ich arbeiteten letztendlich wirklich
zusammen in diesem Papier, um zu versuchen,
etwas von dieser energetischen
und biologischen Arbeit,
äh, wieder anzuwenden, mit einer Menge Hilfe von Karen
und Lisa, die wirklich die Details
von kennen  Die Neurowissenschaften und die eigentliche
Physiologie Ich denke, Karen besonders, dass
Eli wahrscheinlich sagen würde, dass sie
wirklich, wirklich, wirklich kritisch für
un war  Verstehen dieser physiologischen
Systeme
ähm,
aber im Grunde ja, wie können
wir einige der Parameter und
Annahmen dieser aktiven
Inferenzmodelle auf reale biologische Begriffe stützen, damit
wir anfangen können, uns die empirische
Literatur der biologischen biologischen
Literatur anzusehen und uns irgendwie mehr
Inspiration zu holen  Dass, anstatt nur
auf einer abstrakten
Ebene zu leben,
cool, und damit übergebe ich es
Eli,
ausgezeichnet, in Ordnung,
ich
habe es nicht
geteilt  bringt einige
Themen ein, die wir in
keinem der vorangegangenen 50 Papiere besprochen haben,
äh, viele davon waren auch Motivatoren für das,
was
Sie sich vorgenommen haben, zu erforschen, also werde ich einfach in der
Größe zuschneiden und so weiter und Eli, bitte gehen Sie für
alles
Richtig, ähm, also bevor ich mich wirklich mit dem
Material des Papiers befasse, denke ich, dass es nützlich sein könnte, an das anzuknüpfen
, was Jordan gesagt hat,
um
unsere Hinwendung zur Biologie zusätzlich zu motivieren  und Physiologie
hier,
das ist die meistens inaktive
Inferenzmodellierung.
Beachten Sie, dass ich Modellierung sage oder ein aktiver
Physikpraktikant, sozusagen,
Sie brauchen einen Begriff in Ihrer erwarteten freien
Energie oder in Ihrer
Gelenkdichte, die leider die generative
Gelenkdichte nicht die Anerkennung ist  eine, die
Sie oft nennen würden. Ich habe gehört, dass
sie die vorherigen Präferenzen im
Wesentlichen eine Wahrscheinlichkeitsdichte über
sensorischen Ergebnissen nannte, die beschreibt, was
es schwierig ist, hier anthropomorphe Sprache zu vermeiden
, aber na ja, was Sie
jetzt in echten biologischen Systemen beobachten möchten, die Sie
als wir kennen  Ich kann von Peter
Sterling
oder vielen anderen Autoren hören, dass dies nicht
behoben werden kann,
das heißt, Sie wissen, dass frühere
Vorlieben nicht behoben werden können
Die Annahme, die normalerweise
in
Prinzipien wie etwa das Prinzip der freien Energie eingebrannt
wird, ist, dass
ich das tatsächlich ein
wenig auf der Grundlage von Gesprächen moderieren konnte  s mit einigen
Freie-Energie-Prinzipien, Leute,
wenn Sie eine nicht-pfadbasierte,
zustandsbasierte Formulierung des Freie-
Energie-Prinzips haben, dann werden Sie normalerweise
etwas annehmen, das Ergotizität genannt wird,
und Sie werden feststellen, dass wir einen Anhang
über Ergotizität haben, den ich gesehen habe und den Sie
besprochen haben  es letzte Woche in der Folge „Null“,
danke,
dass Sie das verstanden haben, und danke allen im
Publikum und den Zuhörern, die
das verstanden haben.
Die Annahme der Ergodizität
ermöglicht es Ihnen im Wesentlichen, Unsicherheit über
Zeit oder über die Zeit gegen Unsicherheit im
Moment auszutauschen
Sie können also einfach sagen, dass es eine Gaußsche
vorherige
Präferenzdichte gibt, die so viel Präzision oder so viel
Varianz hat, je
nachdem, wie Sie Ihr Divisionszeichen am liebsten setzen
,
und dann ist
es jetzt für alle Zeiten dasselbe,
wenn Sie einen Pfad machen.  basierte
Formulierung verlieren Sie die Verbindung zwischen dem Prinzip der freien Energie
und
konventionellen physiologischen Begriffen der
Homöostase,
weil der Sollwert nun doch nicht
sein kann  alles oder alles
, was Sie wissen müssen, etwas über
Physiologie, Anatomie, um es zurückzubinden,
und das ist wirklich die Motivation, aus der
wir in diesem Artikel kommen, ist, was,
wenn Sie während der Entwicklung frühere Vorlieben erwerben oder lernen müssen,
wie wenig Sie einbacken können
und so  Wir beginnen mit einer Art Überprüfung in
der Arbeit und in diesen Folien. Die Art
von Perspektiven, die wir studieren, studieren
das Nervensystem, studieren das Gehirn.
Eine davon ist die Vorhersageverarbeitung. Ich
denke, das wird wahrscheinlich die
wichtigste für dieses Publikum und in der
Vorhersage sein  Bei der Verarbeitung sprechen wir von
den Wahrnehmungssystemen des Gehirns,
wirklich von den sensorischen Systemen,
die eine ungefähre Bayes'sche
Inferenz durchführen,
also haben Sie Top-Down-Vorhersagesignale
, Bottom-Up-Vorhersagefehlersignale
und es gibt diesen Begriff der aktiven
Inferenz,
der besagt, dass wir im Wesentlichen
Motor behandeln  Ausgaben
als Parameter an das Erkennungsmodell
in einer seiner frühesten
Formulierungen, bevor es welche gab
erwartete freie Energie
Aber letztendlich heißt es in jeder neuen
oder neueren Formulierung, dass wir eine
Vorstellung von Vorhersagefehlern
zwischen Dichten haben, und dies ist eine
informationstheoretische Größe,
also sprechen wir wirklich von einer
Divergenz oder einer Entropie oder einer
Kreuzentropie, die
wir minimieren möchten  das und wir werden das nicht
nur minimieren, indem wir
die Top-Down-Vorhersagen ändern, die
durch den sensorischen Kortex fließen,
wir werden auch diese zusätzlichen
Parameter ändern, die den
motorischen Vorhersagen, den motorischen Befehlen und den motorischen
Referenzen entsprechen, je nach
Ihrer Terminologie  verwenden, um auf sie zu verweisen,
also untersuchen wir in unserem Labor, wo wir eine Art
Biologen der Emotion sind
, oft das Abfangen,
und das ist wirklich eine ziemlich
vage Definition auf der Folie hier,
weil es unter Neuroanatomen eine Menge Diskussionen
darüber gibt, wo das
Abfangen stattfindet  endet und der x-star-Empfang
beginnt, welche genauen Modalitäten
klassifiziert werden sollten, welcher Weg oder ein anderer,
aber wirklich Abhören ist st  Ich beschäftige mich mit einer
Reihe oder Kategorie von sensorischen Modalitäten,
und wenn ich sensorische Modalitäten sage,
erwähne ich das speziell, weil die
Literatur über abfangende aktive
Schlussfolgerungen
dann dazu neigt, das zu nehmen, was wir
die früheste Form der aktiven Schlussfolgerung nennen könnten,
sie geht den Weg der frühesten Form
davon  Die aktive Schlussfolgerung, die besagt, dass ich eine
generative Dichte habe. Ich habe eine Erkennungsdichte. Die
Aktion wird effektiv zu einem Parameter
, um die Erkennungsdichte an die
generative Dichte anzupassen,
und es gibt nicht wirklich eine Vorstellung von
einem internen generativen Modell,
das getrennt ist und Glaube und
Wunsch
so voneinander trennt  In einer Menge Literatur über
abfangende aktive
Inferenz finden Sie Hinweise auf sehr
genaue Priors
oder Sie kennen sogar angeborene Priors über
abfangende Parameter,
und Sie werden diese Vorstellung sehen, dass
Sie aktive Inferenz im
abfangenden Bereich mehr verwenden als
in  die somatische Domäne,
weil Sie versuchen, Ihre
innere Physiologie an eine Vorstellung von a
priori Set Point anzupassen  ts, die
durch die Evolution bestimmt werden
, denkst du, du könntest ein Beispiel
dafür geben? Eli und welche Art von Sollwerten die
Leute denken könnten, in
Ordnung,
mal sehen, ich habe
Kohlendioxidwerte im Blut gesehen,
erwähnte Glukosewerte,
um die Körperkerntemperatur ist wirklich das
eine, zu der ich tendenziell zurückkehre, weil sie
die meiste Zeit wirklich konstant bleibt,
sie kann variieren, aber das ist wirklich eine
inextremis-artige Situation.
Wenn Sie also an die Körperkerntemperatur denken,
gibt es einen Kreislauf, und ich glaube, Sie wissen, dass
Jordan mich korrigiert, wenn ich  liege falsch, aber das
ist wieder das NTS, sind es nicht
die
Kernfaktoren? Ja, okay, ja, im
Wesentlichen im Hirnstamm gibt es
einen Schaltkreis, der den
typischen Sollwert für die Körperkerntemperatur codiert,
und aus einer aktiven Inferenzperspektive
könnte man sagen, dass dies ein ist  Feste Wahrscheinlichkeit
Es kann nicht
durch eine Vorhersage neu parametrisiert werden, die von weiter
oben fließt,
oder vielmehr wird es die meiste Zeit nicht
neu parametrisiert,
so dass es als Vorhersage nach unten fließt und
die  n jeder Temperatursensor im
Körper
kann die tatsächliche Temperatur mit der
gewünschten Temperatur vergleichen
, einen präzisionsgewichteten
Vorhersagefehler zwischen ihnen
berechnen, diese Fehler zurücksenden,
und dann kann das Gehirn sagen, aha, ich muss
einen Weg finden, diese Fehler zu minimieren,
und das wird effektiv
bleiben  Sie in einer Umgebung, in der Sie
Ihre Körperkerntemperatur aufrechterhalten können.
Sie wissen, dass 98,6 Fahrenheit
das Stereotyp ist, das
für Einzelpersonen unterschiedlich ist.
Der Grund, warum sich meine nächste Folie mit
Allostase befasste,
ist,
dass es zwar sprudelnde Parameter wie die
Kerntemperatur gibt
, die sich normalerweise entsprechend verhalten  zu einem Sollwert
wirklich physiologisch haben die meisten Parameter
keinen Sollwert,
sie bewegen sich die regulierten Werte bewegen sich die
ganze Zeit,
so dass Herzfrequenz,
Blutdruck,
Blutzucker, Blutsauerstoffspiegel,
verschiedene Hormonspiegel im endokrinen
System,
Entzündungsspiegel
, mit der Zeit verschoben werden,
und ich erwähnte  Entzündung, weil
Sie aus der Sicht des Körpers dort
wissen  Sie wissen, dass eine Entzündung nicht
etwas ist, bei dem ein Sollwert von Null
Entzündung manchmal angemessen ist,
und wenn Sie glauben möchten, dass Sie
wissen, in welcher Situation die
Anpassung all dieser
Kernparameter physiologisch adaptiv ist,
dann
denke ich, dass
schweres Training und Krankheit es
sind  wahrscheinlich die beiden größten Beispiele,
also könnten wir für schweres Training
über
Erregungsniveaus sprechen,
und das bezieht sich auf das Gleichgewicht der
kooperativen Aktivität in den Zweigen
des autonomen Nervensystems,
aber im Wesentlichen, wenn Sie
rennen gehen,
sagen wir von einem Raubtier oder  Nach etwas Essen
in Ihrem Mädchen, das Sie kennen
, müssen Sie die
Aktivität in einigen Organsystemen verringern,
die Aktivität in anderen Organsystemen erhöhen
und die
zu regulierenden physiologischen Parameter auf die neuen
Ebenen anpassen,
so dass dies ein hübsches ist  gut beobachtete Tatsache
der Physiologie, die
Sie informell kennen
Peter Sterling Ich würde sagen, er hat die
Allostase als Beobachtung erfunden
Das wird gemacht,
er
redigiert dann ein wenig darüber und
sagt, es sollte die
Homöostase als Regulierungsmodus ersetzen.
Anstatt Sollwerte zu haben,
sollten Sie sie mit so etwas wie einer
festgelegten Trajektorie vergleichen,
und im Idealfall, wenn Sie
theoretisieren, sollten Sie dies tun  Gehen Sie davon aus, dass
es keinen
globalen Sollwert für irgendeinen Parameter gibt,
und natürlich gilt dies, wie wir bereits bei
Extremisten erwähnt haben, wenn Sie krank werden,
überschreibt Ihr Körper tatsächlich diesen
Schaltkreis im Hirnstamm
, um die Kerntemperatur zu erhöhen, weshalb
Sie Schüttelfrost bekommen  Sie haben die gleiche
Temperatur,
aber das regulierte Niveau wurde nach oben verschoben.
Es gibt auch einen interessanten
Punkt, wenn Sie für eine Sekunde zurückgehen,
möchten Sie genau das, ähm, in der Art und Weise, wie sich
die Art der Sprache der Wissenschaft auch
hier entwickelt und  Es ist erwähnenswert,
weil einige Leute vielleicht zuhören
und denken, dass
Sie wissen, dass die Homöostase keine Sollwerte enthalten muss,
oder Sie können
eine Art höheren Goldozean haben
Uponio Stasis kann man haben, ähm, Sie wissen, dass
mehrere Ebenen der Kontrolle damit verbunden sind
, und einige Leute haben die
Allostase genauso kritisiert wie einen Ozean, also
gibt es ein Papier von Carpenter
by Carpenter, das genau das
richtig macht, also ist
es,
aber das Problem ist  ist das, auch wenn
das technisch so ist, und
Leute, die wirklich wissen, was sie
tun und ein Konzept der
Homöostase auf diese Weise verwenden, verstehen vielleicht bereits
, dass Sie nicht unbedingt
Sollwerte brauchen,
aber die Realität ist so
Homöostase wird in der Regel so
verwendet, wie sie verstanden wird, da
sie einen Teil dieser Assoziation
mit Sollwerten oder mit einem einfachen
Thermostatmodell hat, im Gegensatz zu etwas
Breiterem, das mehrere
Steuerungsebenen umfasst, und so
einige Leute, die es sein könnten  Einige Leute sind
vielleicht griesgrämig und wollen sagen,
dass Homöostase bereits alle
diese Begriffe beinhaltet, also sollten wir einfach
den Begriff Homöostase für das zurückfordern
, was wir meiner Meinung nach sind  mehr von der Perspektive,
dass wir bereit sind, das einfach aufzugeben,
und es könnte an der Zeit sein, einfach
einen anderen Begriff zu verwenden, um die Leute an
diese anderen Assoziationen zu erinnern, also
säen wir ein wenig Boden,
wenn wir sie verwenden  Der Begriff
Allostase, um einfach nicht mit den Leuten darüber streiten zu müssen,
was Homöostase wirklich bedeutet,
ja, also hat Jordan da völlig
recht, aber ich würde sogar
empfehlen, dass Sie alle
hören, wenn Sie das Papier Homöostase finden können,
ein Plädoyer für einen einheitlichen
Ansatz von rhs  Carpenter, es ist in unseren
Zitaten und Sie sollten in der Lage sein,
den Namen in Google Scholar einzugeben, schauen
Sie es sich an,
weil es wirklich erklären wird, woher unser
Artikel kommt,
als kurze Zusammenfassung dessen, was relevant ist,
was Carpenter in seinem Artikel sagt, ist das
wieder drin  In der guten alten Zeit
lehrten sie Physiologen Steuerungstheorie und Steuerungstechnik
, und dazu gehörten
Sie wissen, Forschungsphysiologen und auch
Kliniker,
und mit damals meinte er wirklich
zurück in wie  die 1940er bis 1960er Jahre,
bevor ein anderer neuer Ansatz
aufkam, und sie sagt: „Hey, wenn Sie ein gebildeter,
mathematisch ausgereifter und fließender
Steuerungsingenieur sind, brauchen
Sie nicht zu wissen, dass diese umständlichen Namen
wirklich nur unterschiedliche Arten sind
, denselben Kuchen zu schneiden
Sie wissen, dass alles ein Kontrollsystem ist, es ist
ein hierarchisches Kontrollsystem, das ist
sehr offensichtlich, sagt er in der Anatomie und
Physiologie, die Sie sich ansehen werden,
er schreibt sogar für eine Physiologie-
Bildungszeitschrift,
und dann fängt er effektiv an, sich darüber zu
beschweren, dass Sie jedermanns
Strohhalm kennen  bemannte Homöostase bis hin zu
diesem Thermostatmodell
und er muss sich 2004 so beschweren,
weil wirklich jeder
das Wort Homöostase irgendwie mit
diesem Thermostatmodell in Verbindung gebracht hat. Globale
Sollwerte wie Körpertemperatur eher als
Blutzucker
und als Ergebnis
gibt es
Vieles von der eigentlichen
Steuerungstheorie ist so
vereinfacht weggekommen
, selbst als jemand, der in einer
Informatikfakultät untergebracht ist  Ich habe einen Kurs
über Verstärkungslernen besucht und kann
die Gleichungen der optimalen Steuerungstheorie bearbeiten.
Ich wurde bis Carpenter nicht in das Konzept eines
Referenzsignals
als zeitvariable Funktion eingeführt,
und das war eigentlich ziemlich aufschlussreich
für mich, anstatt eine Fehlerfunktion zu haben
,
wer
du bist  Kennen Sie das Minimum, dessen globales Minimum
für alle Zeiten festgelegt ist.
Sie können eine Fehlerfunktion haben,
die den Unterschied zwischen Ihrer
tatsächlichen Flugbahn
und einer gewünschten
Flugbahn misst  Homöostase bezieht sich auf diese
Thermiostat-Thermostat-Stilpunktverfolgungssteuerung,
dann bezieht sich Allostase auf die Flugbahnverfolgungssteuerung
,
also bewegen wir uns ein wenig weiter und kehren aus unserer Perspektive
auf die Hauptstrecke zurück, die
von
Physiologie und Anatomie
und ein bisschen Evodivo-
Abfangen und Allostase geprägt
ist  beide haben
sich ziemlich gut
als
wirklich zentral erwiesen  wie das
Nervensystem tatsächlich strukturiert ist
und sich anscheinend weitgehend mit
dem Stoffwechsel und der mangelhaften
Funktion der Eingeweide befasst,
also für jeden, der möchte, dass Sie
Zitate dafür kennen, denke ich, es ist
äh Jordan, es wäre Barrett und wer
2015.
oh äh Barrett und Simmons 2015  .ja
Neurowissenschaftliches Papier ja Naturrezensionen
Neurowissenschaftliche
interzeptive Vorhersagen im Gehirn Es
gibt eine neuere Rezension von
Karen Quigley, unserer anderen leitenden Autorin zum
Thema Interzeption, die 2021 herauskam,
und Sie können es also wirklich selbst überprüfen,
und ich würde Ihnen raten, wie
zentral es ist  Terrezeption und viszerale
Regulation
sind empirisch für das Nervensystem.
Sie könnten möglicherweise ein
Nervensystem für einen Roboter entwerfen, der anders funktioniert,
aber diejenigen, die sich entwickelt haben,
sind allgegenwärtig darauf ausgerichtet, die
inneren Milien des Körpers effizient zu halten,
also
ähm ja
ähm Dan kitzelt ja, macht es Ihnen etwas aus?  wenn ich mich
entschieden habe eine kurze frage hier natürlich
ja weil äh das können die beiden autoren hier
vielleicht  Bestätigen Sie nur, dass mein Fallschirm
richtig gepackt ist, damit möchte ich mich im
Grunde
wohlfühlen, also treten Sie einfach
für eine Sekunde
in dieser Rutsche zurück, damit Sie einfach
dort oben
die Kette und den Schuss hier die Art
von Weben machen, die Sie haben  Die Jungs, an denen
an diesem Papier gearbeitet wurde, waren die Allostase und
die Enterozeption, das waren Ihre Schwerpunkte,
richtig, und dann haben Sie
ziemlich viel damit verbracht, uns
auf den Unterschied zwischen dem diskreten
Zeitaspekt dessen vorzubereiten, was Sie suchen  bei
und die globale Erfassungsrate, weil Sie
sagen, wir können nicht repariert werden, und nur
der eine, der sagt, ich möchte sicherstellen, dass mein
Shooting richtig verpackt ist, und dann
sprechen Sie über Biologie und Physiologie,
also weiter damit  So groß
werde ich Splat gehen oder werde ich in der
Lage sein, dies relativ weich zu landen,
können Sie mir vielleicht einfach
sagen, ob das tatsächlich ein Vergleich ist oder nicht,
eine
Kreuzung, ob diese Dinge parallel laufen  wie
viel von  Das ist Risikomanagement im Vergleich dazu,
wie viel davon strategisch ist.
Ich würde es eher
als Schnittpunkt betrachten, okay, und wenn wir uns
speziell auf Größen
wie die globale Erfassungsrate
beziehen, sollen diese eher strategisch sein
als Risikomanagement oder epistemischer
Wert,
okay
also  Speziell gibt
es ein ganzes Buch über diese, sagen wir mal,
Vigor, die Neuroökonomie der
Bewegungssteuerung von Reza Shadmir,
und es zeichnet in sehr langer Form
ausführlich die empirischen Beweise auf,
dass
echte Organismen ihre Belohnungsrate zeitlich mitteln
, um sich von einer Episode zu bewegen
Wenn Sie sich auf eine kontinuierliche
Kontrolle einstellen, wissen Sie, dass Sie auf eine kontinuierliche,
lebenslange
Einstellung eine gewisse Vorstellung von unbestimmter Zeitkontrolle benötigen. Offensichtlich werden
Sie nicht leben, bis
T Sie wissen, dass T unendlich ist,
aber an der Grenze müssen Sie ein
kohärentes Kontrollproblem
haben  Zumindest für Modellierungszwecke, weil
Sie
das Ende eines Vogellebens
im Labor nicht auf einem Laptop
reparieren können, okay, und es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten, sich zu verständigen  nional zu
tun, dass man diese Vorstellung von
Gott hat und die globale Erfassungsrate
so setzt, dass der Zeitdurchschnitt
die Summe aller Vorteile minus der
Summe aller Kosten durch die Gesamtzeit dividiert wird,
und die andere exponentielle Diskontierung
jetzt für technische Zwecke
exponentielle Diskontierung  macht die Mathematik
und die Berechnungen viel handhabbarer,
und so fanden sie in den frühen 2000er Jahren im
Wesentlichen heraus, dass die echten, Sie kennen,
echten Gehirne
wie Basalganglien, die Sie kennen, und das
dopaminerge
Feuern am besten durch Zeitmittelung angepasst werden,
und dann auf der rechnerischen Seite
ignorierten das alle und taten es
exponentielle
Diskontierung und wenn wir also über so
etwas wie eine globale Erfassungsrate sprechen,
sagen wir nur, dass wir mit den
biologischen Beweisen arbeiten und ein
Modell aufschreiben, das die
empirischen Bindungen, die
Sie kennen, am besten berücksichtigt, wenn Sie zitieren möchten,
versuchen Sie dies  Zu Hause können Sie
gerne auf
exponentielles Diskontieren umsteigen,
es ist in Ordnung oder die Machine Learning
Community  beginnt,
pünktlich Papiere herauszubringen, die im Durchschnitt
der letzten paar Jahre liegen,
und das ist eine weitere kurze Frage,
dann natürlich, ja, danke für
diese Erklärung. Wenn wir
also die Frage nach der
Nachvollziehbarkeit aufwerfen  das setzt voraus, dass
dieses Ding, das
wir uns ansehen, eine Art Glätte oder Fließfähigkeit hat. Was
ist das? Was ist das? Was ist das? Was ist das? Was ist das?
Dass ein
Fehler, den
ich sagen würde, die Glätte ist das
Glätten, das ist der Schlupf zwischen Karte
und Territorium.
Okay
, wenn wir also über echte Gehirne sprechen,
wissen wir, dass wir die Zeitmittelung
im Territorium beobachten,
was wir nicht tun können, ist, einen Algorithmus dafür zu schreiben
Erzeugt nachweislich eine korrekte Zeitmittelung
und funktioniert in der Praxis in der Technik.
Okay
, sagen wir also eher als Karte und
Territorium, weil der Wissenschaftler auch eine
Karte
hat. Sagen wir, die Abweichung ist dazwischen  In
empirischer Wissenschaft und Technik
und wenn wir unser Modell schreiben,
versuchen wir wirklich, die empirische Wissenschaft anzusprechen,
und es macht uns nichts aus, wenn Ingenieure, die
Sie kennen, ihren kleinen
Ausrutscher machen
und etwas verwenden wollen, das die
Algorithmen einfacher macht
, das ist in Ordnung
, wissen Sie  und in der Tat ist das, was die
Deep Active Inference Community macht,
okay, also gehen wir ein bisschen mehr zurück in
Richtung aktive Inferenz,
wenn wir all dieses Zeug lesen, das ist
eine Art Bibel für unser Labor
Sterling und Laughlin
, an dem Simon Laughlin beteiligt war
Einige der frühesten Veröffentlichungen über
prädiktive Codierung in der Netzhaut von Fliegen
Peter Sterling ist der Urheber des
Konzepts der Allostase,
und was wir tatsächlich bemerken, ist,
wie bereits erwähnt, diese Art
von Schlupf ein weiterer Schlupf oder
Widerspruch,
so sagt man, wenn man eine Belohnung bekommt
Dopamin wird freigesetzt,
dies ruft einen Hauptalgorithmus des Verstärkungslernens auf, den
Sie kennen. Seien Sie vorsichtig mit neuronalen
Schaltkreisen, die wir nicht untersuchen  ng im
Detail für den Moment
, das ist Vorsicht, wie stark wir eine
Aussage über ihre Funktion machen,
und dann beziehen sich die meisten empirischen Beweise, die
sie in dem Buch überprüfen, auf die
Energieeffizienz des sensorischen Feuerns,
also versuchen wir wirklich zu sagen, dass wir wollen
sich von
etwas zu bewegen, das auf der Minimierung einer
Vorhersagefehler-
Variationsinferenz
basiert, zu etwas, das
idealerweise mit einem Optimalitätsprinzip in der
Kontrolle begründet ist,
also gibt es einige Argumente für
Neurowissenschaftler,
die mehr oder weniger darauf abzielen,
den Ewing-Neurowissenschaftler davon zu überzeugen, dass
Menschen, die Interzeption studieren, und Menschen
, die motorische Neurowissenschaften studieren
Sie müssen zusammenarbeiten, um die
Eingeweide zu untersuchen.
Sie können die Eingeweide nicht untersuchen und
den motorischen Zweig des viszeralen Nervensystems
und die Funktionen dieses motorischen Zweigs ignorieren.
Jetzt wissen Sie, dass unsere Aussage, dass
Sie Vorhersagefehler nicht einfach minimieren können,
könnte man fragen  Was ist mit aktiver
Inferenz,
und
da müssen wir vorsichtig
mit dem Begriff aktiv in sein  ferenz,
weil Sie wissen, wie ich es
mir persönlich ausführlich erklärt habe,
gibt es zumindest die zwei verschiedenen
Arten der aktiven Schlussfolgerung. Es
gibt diese sehr alte
ähm, ich glaube, es war Adams 2013
Motor, den
Sie im Motorsystem kennen,
und dann gibt es diesen Begriff der
entscheidungsaktiven Inferenz,
bei der Sie eine erwartete freie Energie haben,
explizite vorherige Präferenzen und so weiter und
so weiter,
und wenn Sie mit der aktiven Inferenzgemeinschaft sprechen,
wissen Sie, dass Sie die Papiere lesen können, die sie
schreiben können  Für ihre eigene Gemeinschaft
würde ich Ihnen besonders empfehlen,
den internationalen Workshop über aktive
Inferenz zu kennen, von dem ich glaube, dass
er nächstes Jahr eine Konferenz sein wird.
Sie haben drei Jahre lang sehr gute
Artikel, in denen viele Autoren die
expliziten Verbindungen zwischen
aktiver Inferenzkontrolle und
optimaler Inferenz skizzieren  Kontrolle
usw.
Also wirklich, wenn wir gleich sagen, dass Sie
wissen, dass Sie keine aktive Inferenz verwenden,
um motorische Funktionen zu reduzieren  Was die sensorische
Funktion
angeht, sprechen wir mit einigen Psychologen und
Philosophen
, die
, sagen wir, ziemlich begeistert von der
Vorhersageverarbeitung,
aber ein bisschen eliminativistisch in Bezug auf einige
der mathematischen Konstrukte sind, die
tatsächlich in der aktiven Inferenz verwendet werden,
also haben wir für unser Psychologenpublikum
wieder einmal etwas  das Argument, dass wir
im Grunde
zeigen, dass Sie
eine vollständig probabilistische Vorstellung von optimaler
Kontrolle machen können und sollten
, um herauszufinden, was
mit allostatischer Regulation vor sich geht,
und wir werden uns dabei
von der motorischen Neuroanatomie inspirieren lassen
ein einfaches Modellsystem
und dies kommt in Zahlen aus
dem Papier.
Wir haben unsere afferente Reaktionskurve des Barrel-Reflexes.
Sie haben einen Karotten-Barorezeptor. Er befindet sich in
der Halsschlagader im Hals.
Er misst den Blutdruck
und wir bringen das hier hoch, weil der
Fassrezeptor oft als Modell
in Terassenptor verwendet wird,
wenn ich spreche  d zu Karen und fragte nach
Modellsystemen zum Abfangen,
sie sagte tatsächlich, Sie wissen es gut,
denken wir zuerst über den Kraftrezeptor nach
und wieder mit Widerspruch,
was wir tatsächlich finden, wenn wir uns die
Anatomie ansehen, ist, dass der Barorezeptor, der
Carotis Barrel-Rezeptor,
der sensorische Zweig eines Tiefs ist  -Level-
Steuerkreis,
so dass der NTS dann
nicht hat. Ich glaube, der mittlere Wendepunkt
ist hier im NTS codiert und ändert sich nicht
wirklich viel, aber was passiert,
ist, dass Sie Top-Down-Befehle bekommen können,
die in den MTS fließen
und dann den ändern  Verstärkung dieser
Schaltung,
also die Neigung der Kurve,
und wenn Sie diese Neigung verbreitern,
so dass die Kurve flacher ist
als Ihre Wahrung der
Reaktionsfähigkeit, bleiben Sie, Sie verbreitern den
ungefähr linearen Teil der
Kurve,
während Sie einen Anstieg des Blutdrucks zulassen
Fallen
und so sehen wir wieder für die Interceptor-
Leute,
dass Sie wirklich darüber nachdenken müssen
, was die Rolle dieses
Interceptor bei der
Kontrolle des Körpers ist und wissen  von den Eingeweiden
kann man nicht einfach hinschauen und sagen, es ist ein
Sensor, na gut, es ist ein Sensor, wo
projiziert IT auf den
enterozeptiven Kortex, nein, nicht
unbedingt, wie Sie den Fehler kennen, die
Vorhersagefehlersignale, die den
abfangenden Kortex erreichen, um
zu sagen, dass Sie es wissen  Ich kann nicht genug
Blut pumpen oder so etwas wurde
möglicherweise bereits
von dem verarbeitet,
was meines Erachtens in der motoraktiven
Inferenzliteratur als Reflexbogen
bezeichnet wird  Zeit, in der es die
höheren Teile des Gehirns erreicht,
also legen wir in unserem Artikel einige
Vokabeln fest, die Menschen verwenden können, wenn sie
keine Kapazitätskurve haben wollen,
insbesondere werden
wir sie mit dem Begriff der
kumulativen Verteilungsfunktion verbinden  später
gibt es etwas Physiologie-Terminologie für
Leute, die es lernen wollen,
und dann stellen wir fest, dass
Carpenter
Carpenter und eine Reihe anderer Artikel tut
, nämlich dass
dies ein Ma ist  Ein sehr hierarchisches
Kontrollsystem,
sagen wir, viele regulierte Substanzen
oder regulierte Variablen werden von
mehreren Controllern beeinflusst,
so dass zum Beispiel
die Blutnährstoffwerte nicht nur Glukose,
sondern ich glaube, wie Salz,
Fettwasser,
durch Hormonpaare reguliert werden,
manchmal gibt es mehrere
Hormonpaare  Hormone pro Nährstoff, die
im Blut vorhanden sein müssen,
und dies ist kein konvexer Kompromiss,
also keine antagonistische
Wettbewerbsregulierung, die
sie manchmal zu konkurrieren scheinen,
sondern tatsächlich eine kooperative Regulierung,
die auf der Tatsache basiert, dass
chemische Spezies dies sozusagen nicht können  Kodieren Sie negative
Zahlen so,
wie es ein digitales Signal kann.
Wenn Sie also Dinge mit chemischen
Signalen tun, stellt sich heraus, dass diese Paare
der Weg sind,
den dynamischen Bereich mit der größten Empfindlichkeit zu überwachen und zu steuern,
wie
wir es anhand dieses Beispiels von Glukagon und Insulin sehen können  Diese Art von normalem Blutzuckerspiegel
ist eher ein Bereich
und es ist ein Bereich, in dem Sie ihn
haben werden  ungefähr lineare Reaktion der
Insulinaktivität
und Sie werden die Glukagonaktivität gesättigt
oder wirklich
schwellenwert haben, so dass
Glukagon
bei einem normalen Blutzuckerspiegel
keinen
zusätzlichen Blutzucker aus dem
Darm oder der Leber abrufen muss
es muss nicht nach Fettverbrennung verlangen
Reserviert
Sie im Wesentlichen, dass Sie genug für den Tag gegessen haben, an
dem es Ihnen gut geht.
Insulin reagiert in einem sehr
reaktionsschnellen Modus, in dem es eine
lineare Reaktion auf eine lineare
Änderung geben kann, um Rauschen zu kompensieren
Jetzt können wir Ihnen also tatsächlich näher kommen, wissen Sie
, jetzt, da wir eine kontrollierte Art haben,
über Physiologie nachzudenken
, können wir mehr in Richtung dieser Begriffe der
aktiven Schlussfolgerung kommen,
und hier werden wir auf
einige der
Quellen zurückkommen, die uns motorisch aktiv gemacht haben  schlussfolgerung
eine möglichkeit, über motorische aktive schlussfolgerungen nachzudenken,
ist
das vorhersagegefühl
des gehirns. der reflexbogen im rückenmark
versucht, vorhersagefehler zu minimieren,
indem er die vorhersage mit th vergleicht  Der
Wert, der von einem Propriozeptor abgelesen wird
, ist also wieder eine Möglichkeit, darüber nachzudenken
, ein paar zusätzliche Möglichkeiten zu haben, um
Vorhersagefehler
wirklich zu
minimieren  Das Gehirn schreibt die
Referenzlänge vor, die das
Referenzsignal für diesen Controller ist,
und es versucht nur, die
Differenz zwischen dem, was es von einem Propriozeptor bekommt,
was es liest, der tatsächlichen
Muskellänge und -spannung,
und dem Referenzsignal zu minimieren,
und das ist eigentlich ein sehr I I  Ich würde
es fast eine lustige Schaltung nennen, die man studieren kann,
weil es so gut dokumentiert
ist,
dass da so etwas ist, wie
ich fast sagen würde, wie ein
präzisionsgewichteter PID-Regler,
Sie wissen, wenn Sie ein Mathematiker sind, dann ist ein
Muskel nett  wie eine Feder
Feder sein kann Sie kennen die Dynamik für
eine Feder
Metallfeder dehnen und knirschen
Sie wissen, dass sie um bestimmte Punkte linearisiert werden kann
und Sie können also ju  Schreiben Sie sich
einen LTI-PID-
Regler als Muss für eine einzelne Muskelspindel auf,
und Sie erhalten zwei Parameter,
die vom Gehirn kommen, von denen einer
die Referenzlänge
und der andere sagt, dass Sie wissen,
wie hoch die Empfindlichkeit oder Verstärkung gegen
Störungen ist  dass Sie trainieren sollten
und dies ist tatsächlich, wie Ihre willkürlichen
Bewegungen ausgeführt werden,
also stellt
all dieses Zeug über Referenzen, über das
wir hier sprechen,
nur die
Hypothese auf,
dass die viszerale motorische Kontrolle möglicherweise
nach denselben rechnerischen und anatomischen
Prinzipien funktioniert
wie  freiwillige somatomotorische
Kontrolle statt der Befehle,
die beispielsweise vom somatomotorischen Kortex
kommen, könnten sie von Ganglien im
autonomen Nervensystem kommen,
wobei das übergeordnete
Zentralnervensystem im
Grunde nur grobe
Aktivitätsaktivierungs- oder -deaktivierungsniveaus
für die beiden verschiedenen Seiten des Nervensystems vorschreibt
vegetatives Nervensystem,
das sich dann wieder in dieser gegnerischen
Mode se  mi-Gegner vollständig kooperative
Mode
ermöglicht es uns, die Codierung digitaler
negativer Zahlen zu vermeiden und Ihnen dadurch eine
sehr fein ausbalancierte Kontrolle über die
inneren Milien zu geben,
sodass wir schließlich zu unserer Figur gelangen,
die im Wesentlichen besagt,
ob ich weiß, welche
Ressource Stoffwechselressourcen
Nährstoffe Sauerstoff Kohlendioxid liefert
etwas, das
ich in der Zukunft haben werde,
dann wird mein Ziel sein
, sagen wir nicht, die Unsicherheit zu maximieren oder die
Unsicherheit zu minimieren, sondern wirklich
die Belastbarkeit oder Freiheit zu maximieren,
bleiben Sie im linearen Teil einer
kumulativen Verteilungsfunktion,
wo Sie sein können
reagiert auf jede verbleibende oder bevorstehende
Störung,
und deshalb zeichnen wir hier, dass Sie
diesen Kapazitätsschätzer den Kreis
schließen
und beginnen können, motorische Aktionen durch
aktive Schlussfolgerung
zu steuern, um dieser Präferenz für die
Widerstandsfähigkeit gegen eine Störung der
inneren Milia zu folgen,
die dann ist  gebunden an abfangende Zustandsschätzung
Ihre anderen Zustandsschätzer Ihr a  Tatsächliche
sensorische Servicedienste
und dieser ganze Schaltplan
und vielleicht eine Sache, die ich nur zu richtig hinzufügen muss,
nur um einen Punkt zu unterstreichen, ist,
dass ich denke, wenn Sie hier eine Folie zurückgehen
und wie sich dies auf
die Art des adaptiven Bereichs des
Absetzens bezieht  Punkt auch, und was ich
an diesem Recht wirklich interessant finde, ist,
dass
Sie nicht definieren,
wie wir zu Beginn darüber gesprochen haben,
wie Sie traditionell über
Sollwerte für die Homöostase in einem
sehr traditionellen Thermostatmodell denken, genau das,
worüber Sie sprechen  Hier ist, dass
es tatsächlich
[Musik] gibt,
ähm,
wenn das übergeordnete Ziel des Gehirns, wenn das
Gehirn im Wesentlichen dazu da ist, dabei zu helfen,
das gesamte
biologische System des Körpers zu regulieren und sich an
äußere Umstände anzupassen, die
sich ständig ändern werden
verschiedene Herausforderungen  auf die es
reagieren muss,
dann haben Sie nicht unbedingt einen
Sollwert, aber Sie haben einen Bereich,
wo Sie können,
wo die Physiologie sein kann  am
anpassungsfähigsten an diese Störungen und
Herausforderungen,
und so
denke ich, um es einfach zu vereinfachen,
denke ich, dass diese Idee
wirklich der Kern dessen ist, was wir versuchen, über Radio zu sprechen,
so dass Sie im Wesentlichen
wollen, dass Sie es
arrangieren wo das  Physiologie kann
anpassungsfähig sein, und ja, Sie können sich vorstellen, dass,
wenn die Physiologie so ist, wenn einige dieser
Parameter weit, weit
außerhalb des Zentrums dieses Sigmoids verschoben werden,
Sie ein Problem haben werden
, da sie dies nicht können
An Veränderungen anpassen, du wirst nicht in
der Lage sein, an diesem linearen Punkt
maximaler Anpassungsfähigkeit zu sein, wenn du hier unten
in der Nähe der Schwelle
bist und du zufälliges weißes
Rauschen erfährst, das dich offensichtlich über diese Schwelle drückt
ist kein diskreter
katastrophaler Ausfall,
aber Sie können offensichtlich auch
keine proportionale Reaktion mehr aufbauen,
ja,
Ihr Körper besteht aus physikalischen
Instrumenten, die
eine begrenzte Bandbreite an Reaktionsfähigkeit haben,
ja, und daher unsere Vorstellung o  Fallostase ist
zu sagen,
wenn Sie
den Bereich der Reaktionsfähigkeit erweitern können,
anstatt ihn einzuengen,
oder eher den Bereich der
Reaktionsfähigkeit erweitern, wenn dies möglich ist, während
Sie die Menge der Zustände oder die
Verteilung der Zustände, in die Sie tatsächlich
fallen, eingrenzen
etwas
gegensätzliche Dinge
und und so wäre es auch
richtig, dass Sie ähm,
es gibt verschiedene Möglichkeiten, wie Sie
diese Systeme irgendwie maladaptiv
werden lassen können, wenn das, wenn das, wenn das, wenn das, wenn das,
wenn das Sigmoid steiler und
steiler und steiler wird, wo Sie im Grunde sind
Es ist nur ein sehr sehr enger Bereich,
in dem Sie tatsächlich eine adaptive
Reaktion haben können, die ein
potenzielles Problem
darstellen kann  viel
mehr Arbeit und viel mehr Kontrollen oder
viel mehr Kontrolle über dieses System erfordern
, um es wirklich weit außerhalb dieses
Bereichs zu bringen  e sich tatsächlich anzupassen, um es zurück
zu schieben, wirklich, um es wieder zurück zu schieben, ja,
was auch andere Probleme im Downstream verursachen könnte
, aber der
Punkt ist nur,
dass Sie die Art von Bereich sind, in dem sich dieses
System einpendeln soll, ein Bereich ist  wo
es sich an Veränderungen anpassen
und sich auf schwankende Umstände vorbereiten kann,
ja, also
denke ich, eine gute Intuition, mit der
wir gehen können, da wir gegen
Ende der Stunde ziehen,
ist,
wenn Sie versuchen würden,
abfangende Unsicherheiten zu minimieren,
was dann  Sie könnten einfach die ganze Zeit zu Hause bleiben,
Ihre Herzfrequenz wird nie zu stark nach
oben und unten schwanken,
und wir leben in der modernen Welt,
in der Sie nicht vor Tigern davonlaufen müssen,
damit Sie wissen, warum Sie sich mit der
Unsicherheit auseinandersetzen müssen  Ausgehen und Trainieren
oder die Störung des Ausgehens und
Trainierens,
und was unser Begriff der Allostase
Ihnen hier als Antwort sagen könnte,
ist, dass,
wenn Sie ausgehen und trainieren, die Kurve
breiter wird
und somit der adaptive Bereich wo  Sie
können eine proportionale Reaktion
aufbauen, die breiter wird,
also gehen Sie raus und trainieren Sie, weil es
tatsächlich Ihre Widerstandsfähigkeit gegenüber
Physiologie gegenüber zukünftigen physiologischen
Herausforderungen erhöht,
so dass es immer noch innerhalb des aktiven
Inferenzsatzes von Intuitionen ist, aber wir
backen wirklich in dieser Annahme, dass
Sie sich präventiv vorbereiten sollten
gegen mögliche Herausforderungen
anstatt
wirksam statt zu handeln, um
mögliche Herausforderungen zu vermeiden,
wir haben den Umgang mit Herausforderungen
in den Körper verlagert,
äh Dean, machen Sie weiter,
wenn Sie zu diesen Extremen dieser
Krisenmomente kommen, über die
wir am Punkt Null ein wenig sprechen  Wie ändert sich
das Zusammenspiel oder der Unterrichtsanteil
zwischen etwas, das interaktiv ist, und
und der Bereich, der versucht, den
Bereich wieder einzugeben? Ich bin neugierig
, ob sich die Formalismen ändern, wenn
diese Extreme erreicht werden, denn
wie Sie sagten, tun die Dinge nicht  Es wird nicht immer
katastrophal, du bist irreversibel
katastrophal,
um
Stat. Also, was könnte dir gefallen, basierend auf
was?  ie Jungs haben sich offensichtlich angesehen
,
wie sich das Verhältnis zwischen
Interaktion und Anweisung verändert, wenn
wir an diese wirklich harten Grenzen kommen,
äh Jordan, du bist oft ein bisschen besser
in Physiologie als ich, willst du das
nehmen, oder
oh  Nein, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ich glaube, Sie
könnten es haben,
also
mal sehen,
ich bin ehrlich gesagt nicht so gut in Physiologie,
weil ich mich auf Karen verlasse.
Ich würde fast sagen, dass es hier einen Kartengebietsfehler gibt,
wo wir versucht haben, so zu modellieren
normale Funktion
unter
normaler Funktion zu sprechen, mit dieser Intuition
über Widerstandsfähigkeit gegen Herausforderungen, okay,
und es gibt mehrere mögliche Reaktionen
auf einen extremen Umstand, von dem
Sie wissen, dass einer davon ist, dass ein hochrangiger
Kontrollmechanismus diese Betriebspunkte außer Kraft setzen
kann
und sie von dort wegdrückt, wo sie
normalerweise sind und  Dann können Sie mit
extremen Umständen umgehen, indem Sie sie überhaupt nicht mehr
als Fehler behandeln.
Sagen Sie, wenn Sie krank sind, ist
Ihre Körperkerntemperatur
nach oben moduliert, was Sie in einen Fieberzustand versetzt,
das ist metabolisch teuer und es
fühlt sich im Vergleich zu
Ihrer normalen Funktion schlecht an, aber es sollte
die Keime kochen,
und dann, wenn der extreme Zustand Sie weiß,
wenn dieser Notfall vorbei ist, werden
Sie hoffentlich normalerweise in der
Lage sein  Um zur normalen Funktion zurückzukehren,
gibt es natürlich Ausnahmen, wie z
Ich denke, sie erkennen einfach,
dass sie einem Abfallpunkt immer
näher kommen.
Ich denke, das ist eigentlich eine offene und
empirische Frage. Okay, einer der
Gründe, die uns gefallen, ging so weit
, ein vollständiges mathematisches Modell zu schreiben  in
diesem Papier
ist, weil sie
oft nicht so viel
empirische neuroinformatische Arbeit zum Thema
Abhören gibt. Wenn Sie also sehr
grundlegende Fragen stellen, wie
ist das Abfangen vorhersagbar codiert?  Tief
im Nacken
, das ist noch eine offene Frage.
Es könnte sein, dass periphere und
Pterozeptoren nur ein
Stimulussignal umwandeln
und es dann nur vorhersagbar kodiert wird,
wenn es das Gehirn trifft, das wir noch nicht wissen,
also hätten wir lieber einen
kurz verlorenen Eli, den wir haben.  Ich habe ihn verloren, aber okay,
während Eli wiederkommt, okay, sehr
interessant,
ein anderer Weg
durch das gleiche Material,
Dave, wenn deine Frage für Eli ist, können wir
ein paar Sekunden warten,
nicht unbedingt,
ähm, ich habe nur eine Nebenbemerkung, auf die du
nicht unbedingt antworten
musst  Die Diskussion erinnert mich an zwei
verschiedene Fehlschlüsse. Einer ist der Fehlschluss der Dunkelkammer.
Wenn Sie minimieren möchten, ist
dies eine Art Parodie auf aktive
Schlussfolgerungen. Wenn Sie nicht überrascht werden möchten, bleiben Sie
einfach
In einem dunklen Raum, in dem sich nichts
ändert, was
von aktiven Versicherungsaktivisten ziemlich gründlich
abgetan wurde, gab es auch eine
Art Irrtum, eine Art sozialdarwinistische
Interpretation der
Beobachtung  t jede Spezies hat eine feste Anzahl von
Herzschlägen und deshalb stehen wertvolle Menschen,
Abgeordnete und
Geistliche nicht zur Arbeit, weil Sie
Ihr Leben richtig auffressen, was natürlich
nicht stimmt, weil Ihr Herz
langsamer schlägt, so dass es sich ausdehnt
mehr, wenn Sie in guter Verfassung sind,
aber relevanter,
um die Steilheit der Reflexkurve. Ich habe
manchmal das Gefühl, dass Leute, die mit
aktiver Inferenz arbeiten
, zu viel von der Vorstellung von
Präzision halten, dass dies eine Größe ist
und so aussieht  Diese Steigung in der
Blutdruckkurve, aber das
könnte etwas sein, was
eher unter den Begriff Präzision fallen würde, und wenn ja,
sollte das ein differenzierterer Anteil sein
, anstatt
nur eine einzelne Zahl zu sein, die in
vielen, vielen Fällen zutrifft  Bereiche der Kontrolle und
Wahrnehmung
, die interessant sind,
also wird das Präzisionsrecht
normalerweise auf die Vorhersagen angewendet, also
gibt es eine Vorstellung von
der Präzision der Vorhersage
Anwendungen angewendet werden, und in diesem Fall denke ich, dass
die Idee eher von ähm ist,
also kommt es darauf zurück, wo
Sie vielleicht über frühere
Präferenzen sprechen, die in aktiven
Inferenzmodellen angesprochen werden,
ähm, und ich denke, die Steigung der
Antwortkurve dort ist stattdessen  Der Versuch
, diese Verwendung früherer Präferenzen richtig auszurichten,
also versucht es, gezielt darauf abzuzielen, wo
ist ähm,
wo versucht das System, navigiert zu werden
? Es war
ja, wenn Leute über frühere
Präferenzen sprechen, haben sie
manchmal darüber gesprochen, was
das System hat  eine Art starker Prior
starker präziser Prior, der kodiert wird,
ähm,
wie a priori prior kodiert wird
, um ins Visier genommen zu werden,
und in diesem Fall, ähm
, versuchen wir zu erklären, woher
einige dieser Prioren kommen können und
wie diese  Systeme und wie Art von
Gegenprozessen
oder Gegenchemikalien helfen können
, die Physiologie zu regulieren,
und wir versuchen, einen natürlicheren
Ansatz dafür zu finden, woher diese kommen können
t
Ich denke, ähm,
wenn es ersetzt wird, versuche ich nur zu
denken, laut mit Think Through die Frage zu sprechen,
also
ob es im Grunde eine vorherige
Präferenz ersetzt,
und ähm,
wenn diese vorherige Präferenz normalerweise
von
einer Art Präzisionskonto behandelt würde  Es ist
dann bis zu einem gewissen Grad das
äh, die Steilheit dieser Kurve versucht, es zu bewältigen, äh, es ist so etwas wie ein Ersatz
für die Präzision, aber
ähm,
aber ja, es ist, äh
, es gibt eine andere
Art von ähm,
ja, vielleicht ist es ein Ersatz für die
Position darin  Fall
Eli ist zurück, also vielleicht kannst du versuchen,
deine Frage zu beantworten. Eli, willst
du deine Präsentation abschließen,
ähm, aber wenn du nur die
Frage beantworten willst, ob wir über die Verstärkung
auf einer dieser Signoidkurven sprechen,
dann
ja, das ist so eine Art  Ersatz für
die Präzision, aber es denkt wirklich
darüber nach
, denkt
genau
andersherum darüber nach, also quantifiziert eine Varianz Ihre Toleranz für Fehler. Eine Präzision oder eine Verstärkung quantifiziert die Reaktion auf Fehler. Ja, ja, so  Wenn Sie über rein
sensorische
diese zusätzlichen rezeptiven
Signale sprechen, diejenigen, die
Ihnen in keiner Weise Referenzen vorschreiben,
dann wissen Sie natürlich, dass Sie
die neuronale Reaktion speichern möchten, die
für präzise Signale metabolisch teuer ist,
wenn Sie darüber sprechen  eine interne
Sie kennen physiologische Kurve
sagen Reaktion auf eine Änderung des Blutdrucks
dann möchten Sie versuchen
, die Verstärkung flacher zu machen Sie möchten
Abweichungen tolerieren
Entschuldigung,
dass
ich mein Heimmodem bekommen habe.
Ich glaube, es hat
sich ohne ersichtlichen Grund neu gestartet. Wir nennen
das a  Schlaf-Wach-Zyklus
Ja,
ähm, wie wäre es mit ein paar
Aktualisierungen des Schlafphasengradienten,
aber es ist einfacher, es ist aktualisiert,
ähm, es ist bereit, dass Sie die Präsentation abschließen,
und dann werden wir
zurückkehren, sehr ähm, interessant, aber
also
okay,
ähm,
sehen Sie sich hier den Bildschirm teilen an, wir sind in Ordnung, fahren Sie
fort
Ja, also fangen wir jetzt an,
uns wirklich mit dem spärlichen
Bildmaterial zu befassen, das für Abschnitt vier verfügbar ist,
was wir, denke ich, in a im Detail durchgehen müssen
mehr q ein bisschen formatieren,
aber wenn wir dann darüber sprechen wollen, wie
wir entscheidungsaktive Inferenz
in diese allostatische Sichtweise integrieren,
dann können wir sagen, dass Entscheidungsfindung dieser
Begriff der optimalen Kontrolle ist
, die einer Reihe von Erwartungen über die Zukunft unterliegt,
also wir  Wir müssen eine objektive Funktion schreiben,
und dann haben wir unseren Schaltplan
zurück,
und wir stellen fest, dass
die von oben nach unten ausgegebenen
Motorreferenzen jetzt von Vorhersagen über die Zukunft abhängig oder abhängig sind,
die
dann Teil dessen sind, wie wir kommen werden
Um zu verstehen, woraus diese Zielfunktion tatsächlich besteht, nehmen Sie zunächst die Intuition, dass wir, wenn wir von neuronalen Schaltkreisen ausgehen
, die nur die Vorhersageverarbeitung durchführen können,
wie wir sie kennen
, eine Sache, die wir damit tun können,
Sie wissen, ein Ensemble oder eine Population simulieren können
von möglichen
Zustandsverläufen oder wirklichen Zustandshandlungsverläufen
ausgehend von einem Anfangszustand,
dann wissen Sie, dass wir bei gegebener objektiver
Funktion
den
Zeitdurchschnitt in Anbetracht unseres Sinnes schätzen können
mble können wir das in eine Rückkopplungssteuerung umwandeln, indem wir
die Stabilität in der Steuerungstheorie erhalten, die
Stabilität des geschlossenen Regelkreises, die sich aus der
Verwendung von Rückkopplung ergibt,
indem wir dann ein Erkennungsmodell haben,
und dann können wir sagen, ah,
ich werde mein gesamtes Ensemble
oder meine Population
von Simulationen aktualisieren,
indem ich sie nehme  Aus dem
Erkennungsmodell,
das von beobachteten sensorischen Ergebnissen abhängig ist,
und dann mit Vorhersagen aus der
Erkennungsdichte,
die wir hier mit
hochgestellten Klammern auch
im Vergleich zu hochgestellten
Klammern hier
hochstellen, können wir dann einen Begriff der Entfernung bestrafen,
so dass wir es wirklich können  bestrafen Sie die
Quote-Unquote-Größe des Updates
in informationstheoretischen Begriffen,
und wenn Sie eine freie Energie oder eine
erwartete freie Energie gesehen haben, die Term für
Term ausgeschrieben wurde, bevor
Sie eine davon gesehen haben sollten, ist dies eine
KL-Divergenz,
aber was uns das gibt, ist  Feedback
stabilisierte Kontrolle
mit Wahrscheinlichkeitsmodellen
und das kommt eigentlich mehr oder weniger
zum Ende der Folien pro  Se
, da einige zusammenfassende Punkte
sind,
gibt uns das Rechenmodell eine nützliche Vorstellung von Erschwinglichkeitswettbewerb.
Führen Sie im Grunde eine Reihe von Vorwärtssimulationen durch.
Wählen Sie
diejenigen aus, die im
Laufe der Zeit gute Erwartungswerte haben werden, um
tatsächlich
als Motorreferenzen
die
Sigmoidalkurven zu erlassen
Nachdem wir ihre Ableitungen genommen haben,
um sie in Wahrscheinlichkeitsdichten umzuwandeln,
wissen Sie, dass Sie dann den Logarithmus
dieser in logarithmische Dichten umwandeln,
was für Sie viel typischer ist, wissen Sie,
aktive Inferenz wie eine logarithmische Prioritätspräferenz,
die tatsächlich eine Vorstellung von einer
gemeinsamen
Fremdwährung liefern  Weil wir jetzt
alle Begriffe der Wahrscheinlichkeitsmasse auf eins normalisiert haben,
sodass eine Dichte über einer Variablen und eine
Dichte über der anderen Variablen
dieselben Einheiten
haben, brauchen wir in diesem Modell keinen weiteren Begriff einer
Belohnungswährung, als
es einige gibt  Ermutigung
für die Anatomen und Physiologen zu
sagen: „Hey
, schauen wir uns die autonome und viszerale
motorische Regulation an
und sehen, ob  Wir können es
in Bezug auf diese Motorsteuerkreise
auf niedriger Ebene verstehen,
und das bringt uns nur zu einigen
sehr allgemeinen Schlussfolgerungen.
Idealerweise sollte unsere Arbeit in einen
Dialog mit Ihnen gestellt werden aktive Inferenz
als Kontrollarbeit von anderen Autoren
und natürlich Danksagungen  Sie können
hier wirklich sehen, wie viel
Arbeit im Namen von absolut jedem
im Team
und den Referenzen hineingesteckt wurde,
also werde ich aufhören zu teilen und wir können zu
einem interaktiveren Format wechseln,
großartig,
danke
, dass Sie das geteilt haben, und wo wurde das
zuvor geteilt?  Welcher Kontext
ähm nur im Kontext unserer Laborgruppe,
alles klar, cool,
also werden wir die College of Engineering-Gruppe schieben, über die
wir gesprochen haben, ja,
ja, also sind die Folien wirklich dafür gemacht,
wie
Biologen, Psychologie, mit ein paar
Ingenieuren, Gruppe,
cool,
gut  viele,
viele Wege, viele Wege zu gehen,
nur um ein paar Stücke
unter diesem
breiten Schirm der Physiologie hervorzuheben. Ein
wichtiger Punkt, den Sie angesprochen haben,
war, wie viel
Hom  Eostase Die
gleiche
Stasis
ist wirksam gegenüber einem Mechanismus, der
tatsächlich darin besteht, dass die Stabilisierung manchmal
empirisch von Stasis
und sogar Homöostase
ist, die unter Lane durch einen Antrieb auf einen Sollwert erfolgt,
wie er vereinfacht oder
wie in diesem einfachen Thermometermodell verstanden wurde
und dann in welchem ​​​​Umfang  Bringen wir
allostasis hormesis Erregung
und andere physiologische Phänomene ein
und betrachten diese alle als Teil der
dynamischen und multimodalen homöostatischen
Interaktionen komplexer Körper
im
Gegensatz zu dem alten und dem neuen und wie
sehr wir die Physiologie in einen Topf werfen und spalten, selbst wenn es sich
um eine Einzelzelle handelt  Auf der Ebene der Lebensformen beteiligen
sie sich
aus einer rechnerischen, kontroll- oder
informationstheoretischen Perspektive an
Prozessen, die einigen dieser analog sind.
Das ist ein Punkt, den wir untersuchen können. Ein
weiterer zu untersuchender Bereich
betrifft das Thema, was diese Systeme
tun
und wie wir es tun  Modellieren Sie es das Kartengebiet
oder die
ähm ingenieurwissenschaftliche Grundlagenforschungsfrage, über die
wir eine gegebene sprechen könnten
Physiologischer Prozess
Stabilisierung der Körpertemperatur oder der Barorezeptor
Glukose und so weiter
gibt es die Minimierung eines
Unterschieds
zum Beispiel zwischen bevorzugt und
beobachtet
gibt es eine Maximierung der Belohnung
Gemäß einer Belohnungsfunktion
gibt es eine Maximierung der Präzision
Präzision,
was eine Maximierung ist  der Empfindlichkeit,
die in der Familie der sigmoidalen Kurven dem linearisierten Bereich entspricht. Gibt
es Fälle, in denen alle vier dieser
Dinge
ununterscheidbar auftreten? Gibt
es einen Fall, in dem einige dieser
Phänomene auf Kosten anderer auftreten?
Können
wir Modelle und tatsächlich unterscheiden?
machen einzigartige Vorhersagen, Erklärungen und
Kontrollsysteme,
wenn wir unseren Schwerpunkt von einer
dieser Linsen auf eine andere Linse verlagern,
und wie sollten wir über verschiedene
physiologische Systeme nachdenken, die von den
impliziten und sehr
alten Mechanismen
bis zu solchen reichen, die sich bewusst sogar
wie beispielsweise Fehlerminimierungsbelohnung
anfühlen  Maximierung  Genauigkeit
Maximierung Reaktionsfähigkeit Maximierung
Also werde ich hier
innehalten und entweder Autoren können
einige Bemerkungen machen oder jemand kann eine
Frage stellen oder dachte
Eli Ich wollte Sie nur bitten, vielleicht nur
innerhalb dessen zu leiten, weil Sie
am Ende darüber gesprochen haben,
dass uns das erwischt  weg von der
Notwendigkeit, eine Belohnungswährung zu haben,
oh ja, und vielleicht wäre ich interessiert, wenn
Sie das ein wenig näher ausführen könnten,
also
nur, was wäre die typische Rolle einer
Belohnungswährung und
wie funktioniert das?  Framework,
dass Sie vorschlagen, das richtig zu ändern,
ja, also würde ich wirklich zurücktreten und sagen, dass Sie
wissen, was sich ändert. Dies ist der aktive
Inferenzstandpunkt, also
zitieren Sie normalerweise nicht, wenn Sie so
etwas wie
ähm tun, wenn Sie jemand sind  Yale Neve oder
Sam Gershman, dann denken Sie über
Belohnung im Sinne eines verstärkenden Lernens als
etwas, das das Gehirn maximieren muss,
und dann würden Sie sagen, in Ordnung, ich
möchte, dass
die Unsicherheit meiner Überzeugungen
minimiert wird  Während ich die Belohnung maximiere
, sind das dann zwei separate modulare
Berechnungen, die fast entgegengesetzte
Ziele haben. Eine davon besteht darin, die
Unsicherheit im Moment zu minimieren, und die andere darin
, die Belohnung langfristig
und die Einnahmen zu maximieren. Sie kennen aktive Schlussfolgerungen
und sagen wirklich nein, wenn Sie  Wenn Sie dies
als Variationsoptimierungsproblem
ausdrücken, können Sie ein einheitliches Ziel
dafür erhalten,
bei dem Sie wissen, dass die gemeinsame Währung
sozusagen ein
Beweis ist.
Sie wissen wirklich, dass Sie Beweise dafür haben, dass Sie
der richtigen Flugbahn folgen.
Beweise dafür, dass Sie einen verhaltensgerechten Handel ausführen
und Beweisserien, die Sie kennen, in Bezug auf
Ich denke, wir würden sie Mücken oder Bits nennen,
sind die Einheiten und die Informationstheorie.
Wenn
Sie also wissen, dass e als Grundlage für Ihren
Logarithmus verwendet wird,
ist dies nicht der Fall, wenn Sie eine Log-2-
Basis verwenden  Es sind Teile, die
meine Hunde für ihre
Spaziergänge aufheben, also
ja, das ist eine sehr interessante
ergänzende Perspektive,
bei der wir im Laufe der Zeit eine Belohnungsmaximierung erhalten,
wenn wir
o erhöhen  Unsere Genauigkeit, darin sind sich nun alle
einig und wird es der
Karren vor dem Pferd oder das Pferd
vor dem Auto sein und wer das Pferd
und wer der Karren ist,
und die einheitliche
Zielfunktion in informationstheoretischen Begriffen
als eine Surprisal-Bounding-Heuristik einrahmen  wurde
in bayesianischer Evidenz untere
Schranken lange Zeit durch Framing der
Überraschungsminimierungsbegrenzung als
einheitliche Zielfunktion und Währung durchgeführt,
dann gibt es die realisierte
Aufrechterhaltung der Homöostase oder wie auch immer wir
das nennen wollen,
ohne dass eine traditionell
strukturierte
Belohnungsmaximierung im Sinne von definiert wird  eine
Belohnungs- oder Zeitrabatt-Belohnungsfunktion
und es ist auch sehr interessant, da
wir nicht versuchen, die Körpertemperatur zu akkumulieren,
wir versuchen nicht,
Glukose zu akkumulieren,
wenn wir ein Spiel spielen würden, bei dem einfach
mehr Punkte besser wären,
wie bei einigen sozialen und subsozialen  Spiele
dann macht eine einseitige Optimierung via
Maximierungsparadigma durchaus
Sinn
aber für die Art von ph  ysiologische
unendliche Spiele, die wir spielen,
wie Sie mit dem unendlichen
Horizont hervorgehoben haben,
dann kann es sinnvoller
sein, eine begrenzte Verantwortung
und eine Betonung der Kontrollierbarkeit
unter vererbten Prioritäten zu haben, dass diese
kontrollierbaren Bereiche die überlebensfähigen
Bereiche sind, wie hätte man sonst
für Generationen existieren können
statt  Versuchen
Sie, Glukose zu
stapeln, ja, also denke ich, dass
es immer sehr interessant ist,
zurückzugehen und Peter Sterling in diesem Licht zu lesen,
weil
Sie wissen, dass es neben dem formalen
physiologischen
Material diese Geschichten gibt, die er
zum Beispiel über Menschen erzählen kann, die unter
Langzeitstress leben  Situationen
und sie entwickeln das, was wir jetzt
Zivilisationskrankheiten nennen würden, von
denen Sie wissen, dass Sterling gewissermaßen
Homöostasekrankheiten impliziert,
die zu oft zu sehr gleich leben,
und tatsächlich, wenn Sie davon sprechen, dass Sie keine
Glukose anhäufen wollen, ist
dies der Fall  dass Sie wissen, dass dies eine tatsächliche
Krankheit ist, die Menschen betrifft und die
als Diabetes bezeichnet
wird  wird als Pathologie angesehen, und so
gibt es
fast einen interessanten Missverhältnis
zwischen diesem intuitiven Begriff der Belohnung
oder
lassen Sie uns zumindest leicht spöttisch sagen und sagen, dass der
wirtschaftliche Begriff der Belohnung,
der eine Form des akkumulierten
Reichtums in einer gemeinsamen Währung sein muss,
versus der Physiologie, in der auch  Vieles von einer
guten Sache ist eigentlich wieder eine schlechte Sache,
richtig, und das kommt darauf zurück
, wenn Sie einen Teil dessen haben, was dies dazu
beiträgt, dann ist in gewisser Weise eine
Art Verschiebung der Metapher richtig, oder es ist,
denke ich, dieser Punkt über a
Eine wirtschaftliche Konzeption und Wert und der
Belohnung
ist
es nützlich, einen Kontrapunkt dazu zu haben
, denn wie Eli sagt,
gibt es keine Obergrenze für die wirtschaftliche
Belohnung, es gibt einen Vorteil, sie zu akkumulieren
, Sie denken darüber nach,
Kapital zu akkumulieren, um es
in diesem Fall auszugeben  Richtig, worauf wir uns
konzentrieren, ist,
wie man im
Grunde ausgeglichen und anpassungsfähig bleibt,
damit zukünftige Herausforderungen
tatsächlich angegangen und bewältigt werden können, und
das irgendwann  s bedeutet, leicht zu packen, nicht
so viel Glukose zur Hand zu haben, damit
Sie sehr gerne mit der Belohnung
umgehen oder mit sich ändernden Umständen umgehen und
sich an sie anpassen können,
aber Sie können nicht
ähm, es ist vielleicht, ja, es war
vielleicht ein ziemlich ernstes Problem
haben diese
völlig abstrahierte Vorstellung von Wert,
dass
ähm endlos akkumulierbar ist und
nicht wirklich mit irgendeiner der
biologischen Realitäten von ähm verbunden ist,
was Systeme tatsächlich tun, genau
dort ist ja, es ist, es ist, also ist es so
abstrakt, dass es ähm,
es ist, es ist  Ich werde es wirklich schwer haben,
mich mit Biologie zu verbinden,
ja, bevor wir zu der Frage kommen,
sagen wir, lassen Sie uns das zusammenfassen, indem wir sagen,
Bankkonten sind unbegrenzt und sie sind
nützlich, weil sie unbegrenzt sind
Dollar an
Vermögenswerten
in einer Weise, dass mein Körper es nicht kann.
Körper sind begrenzt,
wenn Sie wissen, dass sie physisch
begrenzt sind
Versuchen Sie, zu viel mehr in
sie zu stecken, etwas Schlimmes wird
natürlich passieren, nachdem Sie dies in dieser
Kanaldiskussion eingerichtet haben. Ich muss mich
ein bisschen früher zurückziehen, aber ich werde versuchen
, nächste Woche für 50,2 zurück zu sein, und ich bin es
Wirklich interessiert zu sehen, wohin dieses
Gespräch führt, also werde ich
die Hubs nachholen. Danke,
ähm, in Ordnung, danke,
wenn es niemanden
stört  es Dave
oder ähm ist das, was ich gesagt habe
ähm ja ich weiß was das war
ähm wenn du eine neue Frage hast ist es in Ordnung
ich oh ja das ist wahrscheinlich besser ähm
ihre zwei
Teile der Zivilisation es gibt das
Gerücht und vielleicht war das nur ein Trugschluss
oder ein Missverständnis, dass Leute, die es
geschafft haben, während des
Blitzschlags unter Bedingungen, die man
erwarten würde, in London zu bleiben, eine enorme Menge an
psychosomatischen Erkrankungen, Hysterie-
Konversionssyndromen hervorrufen würden, dass es nicht
passiert ist, dass die Leute einfach absurd
gesund waren, weil sie es taten  Ich hatte keine Zeit,
krank zu sein. Sie hatten keine Zeit, verrückt zu sein. Ist
das wirklich passiert?
Hat der Sinn für Mission das außer Kraft gesetzt, was
sonst ein allgemeines Stresssyndrom gewesen wäre
, das Zusammenbrüche verursacht hätte.
Kennt jemand die detaillierte
Geschichte des London Blitz in World?  War
II, weil ich es wirklich nicht tue, es ist eine großartige,
äh, nicht englische Punkt 1,5
um Reise, die wir erkunden sollten, aber um darüber
zu sprechen, ist
es auch eine interessante Frage,
inwieweit wir durch Trost und
Regulierung
überhaupt dagegen arbeiten, geschweige denn
Vernachlässigen Sie andere Kompromisse und ziehen Sie
externe
Effekte nach sich, Dean
Eli, das war fantastisch. Ich, also
hier ist mein Ding,
und ich vielleicht in der in Punkt
zwei. Wir kommen zu dem I, das
ich am Ende des Punktes erwähnt habe  Null,
ich hatte gehofft, Sie hätten
wirklich Samthandschuhe, um mich durch
die 4.4 zu führen, denn
und besonders nach dem Kontext, den Sie
uns heute rund um die Idee liefern konnten,
dass
[Musik]
äh,
Sie kennen Ingenieure und Psychologen
Ich bin jetzt in einen Raum gekommen, ich weiß nicht, ob
das, als du in diesen Raum kamst,
zu einer Kreuzung mit rotem,
grünem Licht wurde, und ihr Jungs irgendwie
einen Red Rover gespielt habt, kommt wegen der Sache oder des
Wetters, und ihr wisst es so gut
hier  Die Sache, weil ich
tatsächlich mit CFOs und Ingenieuren gearbeitet habe und
Sie feststellen, dass es eine Art
Isomorphismus gibt, den
ich für Sie skizzieren möchte, dass das
für Ingenieure tendenziell voreingenommen ist, und dann gibt es noch
die räumliche Umhüllung  Sicht des
Psychologen, als wären sie in ihrem
phänomenologischen Raum, und was Sie getan haben
,
ist, Sie haben versucht zu sagen, was was, wenn
diese beiden Welten zusammenkommen. Ich weiß nicht
, ob es eine Kollision ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob es eine Kollision
ist  eine Zusammenarbeit, es ist eine Vielzahl von
Dingen, richtig, es ist kompliziert, wir
lassen es einfach dabei, aber meine Frage ist,
als ich zu 4.4 kam, fühlte es sich an, als ob
ich Ski fahren würde, ich ging von einem wunderschönen
Pulverfeld zu einigen spärlich
entfernten Bäumen zu Tighter  und Tighter
und fina  Irgendwann dachte ich, ich weiß nicht, wie
ich weitermachen soll, weil
es hier keine Lücken mehr zu geben scheint, es wird
mir einfach zu eng und die
Versöhnung wie beim Skifahren
als Metapher ist du nicht  Wenn Sie
die Bäume betrachten, sehen
Sie das Nicht-Ding an,
es sind die Nicht-Objekte, es ist eine
Versöhnung,
und wenn wir über Völkerball
als Ihre Metapher sprechen oder ob
wir über
Glucagon-Kontrolle sprechen, dann sagen Sie mir, was
Sie beschrieben haben  Bis zu diesem Punkt
sagten Sie im Wesentlichen, dass wir
wissen sollten, was los ist. Wir werden
uns das Risikomanagement
ansehen. Wir werden uns die Koordination ansehen. Wir werden uns
die Dinge ansehen, die im
Wesentlichen rückwärts gerichtet sind  sagen,
dass, damit der Prozess
fortgesetzt werden kann
, diese Faktoren angegangen werden müssen, und
dann muss es die Versöhnung geben, genau
wie wenn die Ingenieure und die
Psychologen nahe
beieinander sind, ist es eine Verstrickung, und
es ist keine  a Die Ingenieure können den
Psychologen genauso wenig sagen, was sie tun sollen, wie
die Psychologen den Ingenieuren sagen können
, was sie richtig machen sollen,
wenn das Verhaltensstück die Idee
der Biologie und der Physiologie ist, wenn
ich dies jetzt in realen Begriffen
tue  Ich muss mir das ansehen, und ihr
hattet einen L4-Zeitrahmen,
richtig, ich kann es schaffen, dass du
klar gesprochen hast, dass ich, ich, das gelesen habe, und es
war mir klar, ich war, ich habe es, ich kann das
koordinieren,
und das war wieder sehr, sehr klar und
dann kam
ich zu 4.4
und ich habe einfach den Faden verloren, weil
ich nach der Versöhnung gesucht habe.
Ich werde diesen nächsten
Schritt mit dem Bereichsrekapitulator abgleichen, den
ich als nächstes erwartet habe, und dann
ging ich in Ordnung, also wo ist die Strategie,
denn das ist da  Wenn
Psychologen und Ingenieure einen
Raum betreten, geben sie nicht einfach ihre
Strategie auf, sie folgt
ihnen in diesen Raum und führt sie zu
der Frage, ob ich
einen Vorteil und all das bis zu vereinbaren habe
Ich wähle diese Option, während ich immer
alle oben genannten Punkte behalte, also sprachen Sie darüber,
dass Sie in anderen Teilen davon sagten,
wir könnten es nicht einfach aufgeben,
aber ich konnte nicht verstehen, wie der
Formalismus es in
Einklang brachte,
also tut es mir leid, dass das so lang ist  -umständliche
Frage, aber Bildpapier, oh, es ist
großartig, sechs Stunden meines Lebens damit zu verbringen
, diese Jungs zu beantworten, diese Typen müssen viel
näher dran sein, weil ich sie
nie beantworten konnte, aber dann habe ich
mich verlaufen und fühlte mich einfach wie oh Mann
Was vermisse ich,
okay, also
werde ich Sie etwas enttäuschen und
sagen, Sie wissen, was Sie vermissen, ist, dass
ich denke, was in unserem Schreiben fehlt,
ist wirklich klar zu sein, dass wir
unter sehr
ungewöhnlichen Einschränkungen arbeiten, wie wir arbeiten  Wir haben
dieses Modell
so spezifisch formuliert, anders als beispielsweise
Sam Gershman Oriel Leave
oder anders als die Literatur zu Deep Active
Inference in Computern,
wir gehen davon aus, dass Sie im Wesentlichen
keine
zusätzlichen rechnerischen
Zutaten für Reinforcement Learning benötigen,
also sagen wir  Angenommen, Sie können
nur die
Rechenoperationen ausführen, von denen bekannt ist, dass
sie an der Vorhersageverarbeitung beteiligt sind,
was können Sie sich einfallen lassen,
um ein Steuerungsproblem zu lösen,
und die Antwort ist diese sehr spezifische
Sache mit diesen unangenehm komplizierten
Ableitungen, die
als Pfadintegralsteuerung bezeichnet werden,
und Sie werden es bemerken  Als
ich diese Folien durchging, sagte ich im Grunde, sagen wir
einfach, Sie können simulieren, dass
Sie mögliche Zukünfte kennen,
wie z
Mittels
eines Erkennungsmodells
oder durch die Integration von Vorhersagefehlern und die
Verwendung von Vorhersagecodierung,
wie bauen wir dann einen Formalismus aus
genau diesen auf,
und der Vorteil ist, dass wir uns dadurch
die Kontrollliteratur ansehen und sagen
können, dass
dies tatsächlich eine
optimale rückkopplungsstabilisierte Kontrolle ist
wir können uns einige der Literatur zur begrenzten
Rationalität
in den Kognitionswissenschaften und Neurowissenschaften
und so ansehen  y unsere objektive Funktion ist eine freie
Energie
, das heißt,
wenn Sie bestrafen müssen, wie sehr Sie
das neuronale Feuern im
Laufe der Zeit ändern
oder wie sehr Sie Ihre Meinung ändern und
Ihre Überzeugungen im Laufe der Zeit aktualisieren,
weil Sie nur so viel metabolische
Kraft in Ihrem Kopf haben,
dann schließen wir es ein  ein Strafbegriff dafür,
und wir können sagen, dass dies alles nur
durch verkörperte Simulation und referenzierte Motorsteuerung erledigt werden kann.
Bedeutet
das, dass das Gehirn
die Dinge tatsächlich so macht, natürlich nicht, dass
Sie wissen, dass es bedeutet, dass, wenn Sie
es tun möchten  Ihre Modellierung mit
Andy Clark neigt dazu, Sie kennen Quine zu zitieren
und zu sagen, wenn
Sie Lust auf Wüstenlandschaften haben, haben
wir Ihnen ein Computermodell gegeben
,
das im Grunde nur aus geschliffenen Steinen besteht,
und als solches ja, es ist etwas  von einer
feindlichen umgebung
kennst du geh ohne rhythm du wirst
den wurm nicht
in den ebenen aktiv ablenken
ja wenn du hinter der schildmauer leben willst
wo wir
um
TD geschätzten wert haben funktioniert gut  Für
Sie
im gestreckten Sigmoid mit breiter
Variabilität, so gestreckt, dass es flach
und einfach ist, aber immer noch
in großen Grenzen gut kontrollierbar ist
, wo wir oszillieren,
ja,
sehr interessant, ich denke, es wird großartig sein,
in unserem Labor ein paar Punkte zu sammeln  von
bin ich derjenige, der wieder ausschneidet
Ich sehe dich immer noch ja
es ist okay ja du bist wieder in Ordnung du
flimmerte ein bisschen okay
ähm in den letzten Minuten können wir
über einige Ideen von früher in
der Zeitung sprechen, schau dir irgendeine der Zahlen an und
dann, Punkt zwei, das wird großartig sein
, sich wirklich dem Formalismus zu nähern und
Dean auf dieser Skireise zu helfen,
ähm,
was wäre etwas, zu dem man in diesen letzten Minuten gehen könnte,
ja, Dean und Just und Eli,
vielleicht bekomme ich eine Chance  um mit
diesem bisschen mehr von Jordan im nächsten Teil näher darauf einzugehen,
aber ich bin neugierig, dass Sie sich Mühe gegeben haben
und großartig bei Great Lengths waren, um zu sagen, schauen Sie,
das spiegelt nicht direkt alle
Komplexitäten wider, von denen wir wissen, dass sie existieren, aber was,
weil Sie gesagt haben  Beginnen Sie damit in
20  19 Sie hatten ein bisschen Zeit
und dann und dann haben Sie das am Anfang irgendwie angedeutet,
gab es Entdeckungen, die Sie gemacht haben
, mit denen Sie nicht gerechnet haben,
weil Sie sehr
respektvoll waren, wen Sie anerkannten
Als Sie hier die Grundlagen gelegt haben
, hatten Sie ein bisschen Stabilität, an
der Sie sich abarbeiten konnten, aber wurden Sie
in Dinge eingeführt
, die nicht da waren, bevor Sie sich darum schlossen,
und glauben Sie, dass
es sich weiter entwickelt oder tut es?
Bleiben Sie einfach auf einer theoretischen Ebene
[Musik],
also eigentlich würde ich sagen, für mich persönlich war
die große unvorhergesehene Entdeckung,
wie wenig wir
über interzeptive Neuroanatomie und
Neurophysiologie wissen,
und ich meine in der Peripherie, damit
Sie unser Labor mit Lisa und Karen
Lisa kennen  kümmert sich um das Zeug über dem Hals,
und so haben wir Sie über Barrett und Simmons 2015 informiert. Es
gibt eine Reihe anderer
guter Artikel, die sagen, dass Sie sich
im Wesentlichen die Gehirnarchitektur ansehen und sie so
aussieht  Zumindest im Cortex
wissen Sie, dass die interzeptiven und viszeralmotorischen
Cortices ziemlich zentral für die
Architektur sind, und dann fragen Sie, okay, also,
welche Arten von Signalen von der Peripherie hereinkommen,
um dann der prädiktiven
Verarbeitung
im Cortex unterzogen zu werden,
und Sie werden im Grunde genommen gut
informiert in Terrezeptiv  Signale offensichtlich,
also gab es diesen Moment, als
ich mit Karen arbeitete und feststellte, oh okay,
also sieht es so aus, als ob es tatsächlich diese
enge Analogie gibt, die wir
zwischen
der bekannten Funktion eines somatomotorischen
Schaltkreises
für die freiwillige motorische Kontrolle
und dieser Art der Handhabung der Barrel-Reflex-
Funktion vermuten könnten
und es sieht so aus, als ob für den Barrel-Reflex, von dem
Sie wissen, dass Sie die
Verstärkung oder die Toleranz freiwillig ändern können, diese
Umkehrungen voneinander sind
, die den Arbeitspunkt ändern, von dem Sie wissen, dass
es nicht passiert, aber
er scheint sich zu verschieben
und es beginnt zu suchen  Als ob
wir einfach aufhören könnten zu sagen, dass
Sie wissen, dass es abfangende Signale gibt, von denen
wir nichts wissen  über sie richtig
und fragen Sie stattdessen, wie wir
das autonome Nervensystem und die
abfangende Peripherie in diese
Sie kennen Regelkreise zerlegen könnten, wo es
eine Referenz gibt, die von oben kommt
oder möglicherweise als Prior eingebaut ist, und
dann ein Sensor und dann ein Motoneuron  oder
ein Effektor
, der wieder total
spekuliert, man könnte sich vorstellen, dass Loop ultralokal sein
könnte
oder sogar zelluläre elektrische Verbindungen bekommen
könnte, so lokal wie möglich,
um den Motorkontrollkreis zu schließen, und dann
gäbe es möglicherweise eine eher meso-
skalige rein innerhalb der Peripherie
ähm vielleicht  eine Art motorische Koordination
oder vasokonstriktionsartige Aktionen
, die durch lokale neuronale
Netze und andere Systeme ausgeführt werden, und wenn
Sie dann das zentrale Nervensystem anrufen
und sich auf dieser Ebene engagieren müssen, ist
dies die höchste Kapazität wie die
Berechnung des intermodalen Gedächtnisses all dieser
anderen  komplexe Phänomene, die dann
vielleicht sogar in einem bestimmten Gehirn ihren rechtmäßigen Platz haben  Region,
aber die gesamte integrierte Dodgeball-
Performance
wird nicht mehr in einer
Gehirnregion lokalisiert sein als
in einer Fingerspitze,
da alles koordiniert werden muss
und nicht jeder Anruf lokal
und nicht jeder Anruf global sein
kann  Herauszufinden, wie Körper als Territorien
und unsere Modelle als Karten
Dinge miteinander verbinden,
wird Modelle schaffen, die besser
interpretierbar sind,
besser auf empirische Daten
abgestimmt sind und nützlichere Vorhersagen und
Erklärungen
machen
Modellierungsparadigma Ich
denke, dies ist eine der wirklichen Stärken
der aktiven Inferenz,
dass Sie, sobald Sie sich mit diesen
Wahrscheinlichkeitsdichten und Log-
Wahrscheinlichkeitsdichten befassen, in der
Lage sind, diese hierarchischen Strukturen zu skizzieren,
und das bedeutet nicht, dass jede
hierarchische aktive Inferenz  Das Modell ist
automatisch eine Karte des
Nervensystems, aber es bedeutet, dass Sie eine
Sprache haben, die mindestens minimal ist  Sehr gut
in der Lage auszudrücken, was wir so
reichlich in den empirischen
Beweisen finden,
ja, ein Teil des
Papiers, der sehr interessant war, was wir
beim Lesen bemerkten, dass,
obwohl die meisten Papiere in Worten geschrieben sind,
dieses sehr wortwörtlich war,
jeder Abschnitt eine
Zusammenfassung des Präambelinhalts hatte
Sandwiching-Technik, wie es das Papier
in einem höheren Maßstab tat, die Nomenklatur
war vorne und klar und dann wurde die
Beziehung zwischen den kumulativen
Verteilungen und den klassischen Wahrscheinlichkeitsdichten des PDF-Typs
klargestellt, aber dies
verbindet genau
etwas, das
im allgemeinen Fall
ein äh garantiert hat  Wendepunkt
interpretierbare Schwellenwerte Aus diesem
Grund werden Sigmoidfunktionen als
Aktivierungsfunktionen in künstlichen
neuronalen Netzen
mit
einer äh optimierbaren Laplace-Näherung
wie
invertierter quadratischer Form
verwendet, die als Log-
Wahrscheinlichkeit verwendet werden kann und daher sehr beliebt ist,
insbesondere mit Abbildung 9,
die die schrittweise zeigt  Beziehung
öffnet die Tür, um „hey if you“ zu mögen
Wenn Sie irgendwo ein Sigmoid gesehen haben
, können Sie sich das jetzt wie ein
PDF vorstellen, das eine PDF-Glockenkurve versteckt,
und wenn Sie dann eine Gaußsche
oder Glockenkurve oder eine Laplace-
Näherung gesehen haben
, können Sie in die andere Richtung gehen und darüber
nachdenken a  sigmoidale
Antwortaktion
und daher sind sie selten so klar miteinander verbunden,
obwohl diejenigen mit Vertrautheit
fast das Wasser sind, in dem sie schwimmen, und
diejenigen ohne Vertrautheit die Verbindung nicht sehen würden
und die Herausforderung und die
Gelegenheit darin bestehen, in der
Mitte zu
bleiben und zu bleiben
im Verbindungsraum
, um die Aufmerksamkeit auf einige dieser Beziehungen zu lenken,
die ansonsten wiederum
ein ganzes Teilgebiet der
Physiologie an der Sigmoid-
Reaktionskurve und ein ganzes Teilgebiet
hierarchischer Vorhersageverarbeitungsmodelle haben könnten, die
im PDF-Raum oder Log-
PDF-Raum arbeiten,
und es ist nur so  eine Ableitung und ein Log oder
eine Potenzierung und eine Ableitung weg
von diesen beiden Feldern, die
formal nicht so wie ein Spekulativ verbunden sind  Das
Rezensionspapier könnte oder sollte jemand tun,
aber wie es fertig ist, kannten wir einfach keine
Werkzeuge, also denke ich, was das Schreiben
betrifft, muss ich wirklich Lisa und
Karen für viele Dinge Anerkennung zollen, von denen
Sie wissen, dass wir mehr von
Dialektik sprechen  Prozesse Sie wissen, dass wir eine
sehr einfache Schreibdialektik auf diesen
Papieren haben, die ist, dass Junior-Autor Mathematik kennt.
Senior-Autoren
haben sich in ihrem
Bachelor- oder Master-Abschluss oder Schlüssel oder
sogar in ihrer Promotion nicht auf Mathematik spezialisiert, so gut sie
jetzt damit sind
und das Ergebnis ist  Sie wissen, dass
Ihnen immer gesagt wird, dass Sie zurückgehen und
jeden einzelnen Schritt erklären sollen, und natürlich
wissen Sie, dass Jordan, der vorher hier war,
viel beim Schreiben und
Strukturieren und Beschildern geholfen hat,
und dann
denke ich, das ist die eigentliche Einsicht, die
Sie haben  kann eines dieser Sigmoide nehmen und
es in ein PDF umwandeln
Ich denke, das kam, nachdem
wir einige Male auf einige der
verkörperten prädiktiven Verarbeitungsliteratur
gehämmert hatten.
Es ist eines dieser Dinge  Das ist
buchstäblich verkörpert,
Dean,
ja, ich wollte das nur in I I bringen.
Was mich an der Zeitung in erster Linie angezogen hat,
war, dass der Alice-Fall
abstieg und das Abfangen,
was mich dazu brachte, darauf zurückzukommen,
und wir sprachen darüber in der  Punkt Null
war
Wegweiser, diese Regel, äh, perfekter
Perspektivenwechsel versus
Wegbinder, als ich anfing, dieses
Papier zu lesen. Ich sah die Metamorphose von der
Identifizierung eines Weges, Dinge zu finden, und jetzt,
nachdem ich heute dieses Gespräch mit Ihnen
und Jordan und natürlich den
üblichen Verdächtigen geführt habe  Es ist
mir klarer, dass dieses Papier versucht,
die Rolle eines
wegweisenden
Perspektivenidentifizierers zu spielen, im Gegensatz zu Wir
haben den Weg gefunden oder dies ist unser Weg
, um alle Übel der Welt zu lösen, was
ich natürlich nicht glaube  war immer Ihre
Absicht, aber wenn Sie Dinge ziehen,
die scheinbar ziemlich weit voneinander entfernt sind, wie
Allostase und Interception, werde
ich aufgeregt, aber ich mache es nicht, wie Sie
darauf hingewiesen haben, pumpen Sie den Bremsdampf
nicht  Zu aufgeregt hier, ich meine,
wir tun unser Bestes, also
funktioniert meine Amygdala auf dieser Ebene immer noch
richtig
in unseren abschließenden Gedanken mit einem
Fahrbeispiel, ob wir Geschwindigkeit akkumulieren oder
die Zeit minimieren oder unsere Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzungen
sogar als externalisiert festlegen
Richtige Normen und stigmerge Markierungen in der
Nische,
so dass eine Vielzahl von Autos, vom
Sportwagen bis zum 18-Rad, in
einer Zone optimaler Beherrschbarkeit sein können, unter
Berücksichtigung des Vorhandenseins von Zebrastreifen
und so weiter und so weiter, wenn wir darüber nachdenken,
was wir tun  Ich möchte Punkt
zwei neben dem Eintauchen in Formalismen untersuchen und
versuchen, einige
Ausgrabungen und Abhörversuche
durchzuführen, wie und wo
die ökonomische Optimierung als
Maximierung implizit verwendet wird
und wo einige dieser anderen Begriffe
aufgeworfen wurden,
ohne polemisch sein zu müssen oder
die Wertmaximierung zu ersetzen
aber wo wir
diese anderen
Überlebensfähigkeitskriterien
als potenziell unterschiedliche
Zerlegungen einheitlicher objektiver Funktionen sehen können, die a  zu
Informationszwecken usw.
Ich denke, das wird ziemlich
weit reichend sein,
weil es mehr Situationen gibt, in
denen wir lieber
Kontrollierbarkeit und Erwartungsgrenzen
und -treffen haben würden,
als Point-Stacking,
also abschließende Kommentare, die Sie mögen,
ja, also möchte ich wirklich schließen  indem
ich noch einmal betont, dass wir nicht wissen, dass wir es nicht sind.
Ich glaube, ich habe diesen Witz auf meinem Twitter-
Profil, die Wertfunktion abzuschaffen, und
das ist wirklich nur ein Wortspiel für die Leute
, die es verstehen können, aber Sie wissen, dass wir es nicht
versuchen  Um den Leuten entgegen ihrer subjektiven Erfahrung zu sagen,
oh, Sie haben keinen
wirklichen
Wert in Ihrem Gehirn
, wissen Sie eigentlich nur, dass Sie versuchen, Ihre Referenzbahn zu verfolgen,
also können wir in der 0.2 darüber sprechen, dass Sie wissen,
welche spezifischen Arten von Feedback
welche Arten steuern  Von Feedback-Mechanismen
wird in diesem Artikel wirklich gesprochen,
und ich denke, wie
Sie wissen, ist es negativ, sowohl
im Sinne der Vermeidung
negativer Verstärkung als auch im Sinne von
o  Wenn Sie versuchen, eine Antwortfunktion zu glätten
und in der Lage zu sein, proportional zu
antworten,
damit Sie im Nachhinein wissen, dass
dieses Papier einen ziemlich
begrenzten Anwendungsbereich haben wird,
aber es ist hilfreich, da es uns eine Sprache gibt, zu der wir uns
wenden können  der Ex zu den
Empirikern und sagen, das ist es, was
wir eigentlich nach
abschließenden Kommentaren suchen möchten, ansonsten ist das eine
großartige Anmerkung.
Nun, Eli und Jordan, danke, dass Sie
herausgekommen sind und sich für dot
Winery engagiert haben, und wir sehen uns nächste Woche,
danke Jungs  bis nächste Woche